Herzlich willkommen bei Alternativlos, Sendung 5.
Dieses Mal eine Sondersendung zum Thema stuxnet und...
Extrablatt.
Extrablatt. Genau, weil wir es ja eigentlich doch hier mit einer Boulevard-Sendung zu tun haben, konnten wir natürlich nicht umhin dieses Thema aufzugreifen. Und wie ihr vielleicht hört, sind wir audio-mäßig etwas aufgerüstet, dank der doch sehr freundlichen und zwar rechten Flitterspenden unserer Höre. Haben wir jetzt ordentliche Aufnahme-Headsets mit den möglicherweise hintergrundgeräuschhal und ähnliche Dinge der Vergangenheit angehören sollten.
Hoffen wir zumindest. Wir haben sicher ein halber trotzdem einen Aufnahmeort gewählt, der relativ geräuscharm ist.
Genau, wir sind nämlich heute in der Seabase in unserer Tradition. Das wäre doch gerne immer wieder einen anderen Aufnahmeort nehmen und mal da bei der Gelegenheit auch so die interessanten kleinen Dinge in Berlin vorstellen, die es in vielen anderen Orten nicht gibt. Die Seabase ist so ein Ort, ja, soziokultureller, technikaffiner Menschen, die hier irgendwie lauter lustige Projekte machen und...
Bis zu einer Mondlandung. Was war das denn, eine Mondlandung?
Genau, sie nehmen hier einen Teil am Google Lunar X-Preis, wo der Wettbewerb darin besteht, einen Mondlander zu bauen, der da tatsächlich auf den Mond geschossen werden soll von einer privaten Firma. Und da gibt es halt diesen Wettbewerb und da nehmen sie daran teil, weil die Seabase hat ja eine interessante Gründungsgeschichte. Sie handelt sich dabei um den ausgegrabenen unterirdischen Teil einer Raumstation, die irgendwann mal in Berlin gecrasht ist in vorvergangener Zeit. Da wurde dann die Stadt drüber gebaut. Der Fernsehturm ist eigentlich nur noch ein Rest der Antenne, der zu sehen ist.
Rekonstruiert von Ulbricht?
Von Ulbricht und die Seabase selber sind die Räume, also die unterirdischen ausgegrabenen Räume. Und diese Raumschüsse, sie haben schon verschiedene dieser Räume ganz über Berlin ausgegraben. Momentan sind sie in der Nähe der Jernowitzbrücke. Und man kann hier auch so Veranstaltungen machen. Und laut der Kleinigkeiten, also kleine Veranstaltungen, sind so eines der Dinge, aus denen die C-Base sich so speist, auch inhaltlich und finanziell. Also wenn man eine kleine Veranstaltung hat, die man gerne machen möchte mit so ein paar Leuten, so in einem interessanten, angenehmen Raum, dann ist hier, glaube ich, Platz. Wurde uns jedenfalls aufgetragen, zu sagen.
Nicht mal. Also auch wenn man hier keine Veranstaltung machen will, lohnt sich der Besuch unter anderem, weil die chinesische Wirtschaft um die Ecke ist. Und die haben die großartigste Antenne auf dem Dach, die ihr hier gesehen habt.
Ich habe schon großartige Antenne gesehen.
Na gut.
Aber nicht in der Berliner Innenstadt. Ja. Also die chinesische Botschaft hat da tatsächlich ein beeindruckendes, beeindruckend großes Gerät auf dem Dach, mit der sie kurz nach Hause punkten und die auch drehbar ist, was auch sehr interessant ist, welche Richtung sie dann immer so drehen. Da kann man auf jeden Fall Dinge beobachten. Soll aber eigentlich heute nicht unser Thema sein. Wir hatten ja gerade unser Thema neue Hardware. Nicht ganz so gut, da ging es wohl vor etlichen Stücken Siemens-Hardware, die im Iran installiert sind, die nun nach dem, wie sich die Indizienlage darstellt, offensichtlich von einem Wurm beziehungsweise Trojaner angegriffen wurden.
Die Lage ist so ein bisschen unimersichtlich im Moment. Man kann ganz gut beobachten, dass die Presse gerade so ein bisschen Blut geleckt hat. Und die befragen gerade jeden, der nicht bei drei auf den Bäumen ist. Und es gab gestern so ein witziges Interview von einem Principal, irgendwas, der Chertov gerupt hat. Das fand ich besonders witzig, die Chertov-Gruppe. Wer sich nicht erinnert, Chertov war mal der Direktor vom Department of Homeland Security, wenn mich recht im Sinne, weil der Chef von Brownie jedenfalls, der Typ, der bei FEMA zuständig war, der bei FEMA zuständig war für Katrina und da größtmöglich verloren hat. Und Chertov hat dafür gesorgt, dass der nicht sofort gefeuert wurde. Und der macht jetzt halt eine Chertov-Gruppe. Und von denen haben sie einen Typen befragt. Und der hat sich in einem Interview einen Klopper nach dem anderen geleistet. Der sprach dann zum Beispiel vom Window Operating System und von Day Zero Lücken. Also man hat gemerkt, jemand hat ihm die Worte aufgeschrieben, aber er hat sie nicht in der richtigen Reihenfolge abgelesen. Und weil wir auch so ein bisschen Bildungsauftrag haben, haben wir uns gesagt, wir machen jetzt mal eine Sondersendung zu stuxnet.
Genau, ich habe ja einen Artikel in der VZ dazu geschrieben, mal so den Stand der Dinge von voriger Woche zusammengefasst, der mir so von etlichen Leuten gesteckt wurde, die tatsächlich an der Premium-Analyse beteiligt sind. Also kurzes Dementi, weder Fefe noch ich sind tatsächlich selbst direkt an der Reverse-Engineering von dem Ding beteiligt, aber wir kennen halt etliche Leute, die da gerade mit beschäftigt sind und haben da doch die ein oder anderen Gerüchte gehört. Die Lage ist hinreichend unübersichtlich, aber wir wollen dann mal systematisch durchgehen. Fangen wir doch mal bei den so halbwegs bekannten faktenähnlichen Dingen an.
Ja, also stuxnet ist gefunden worden im Juni 2010 von einer mir bis zu einem jedenfalls völlig unbekannten Brude in Weißrussland. Namens Viroz Block Ader, wenn die gehört. Also die haben sie jedenfalls zuerst gefunden und das sah ursprünglich aus wie eine typische Mailware, die eine neuartige Lücke ausnutzt. Immerhin dafür ist es bekannt geworden, nämlich die LNK-Lücke unter Windows. Und der Effekt davon war, dass man ein USB-Stick reinstecken kann und selbst wenn man in Windows die ganzen Settings geändert hat, also es gibt da so ein Autorun-Feature, normalerweise wenn man eine CD reinsteckt, dann startet Windows das Setup-Programm. Selbst wenn man das ausschaltet, konnte man über diese Lücke eben trotzdem noch Code ausführen auf dem Rechner. Und das war eine relativ beeindruckende Lücke. Also ich kenne ein paar Leute bei Microsoft in der Abteilung, die sich um neue Lücken kümmern und die waren also relativ beeindruckt von dem Teil.
Also der interessante Punkt an dem Ding war, dass es tatsächlich auf allen Windows-Wehren funktioniert. Also was bisher doch irgendwie nur sehr wenige Lücken geschafft haben, auf allen Windows-Einheiten von irgendwie Windows 2000 bis irgendwie zum aktuellen Windows 7 zu funktionieren.
Es war eine Designlücke. Also wir gehen gleich noch ein bisschen darauf ein, wie denn so das Ökosystem und der Markt von Lücken ist und erklären so ein bisschen die Hintergründe. Wir sind uns ja bewusst, dass es hier eigentlich keine Technik-Sendung ist, aber wir haben uns gedacht, das Thema ist wichtig genug und da gibt es genug Blah in der Presse, dass wir vielleicht mal ein paar Hintergründe bringen sollten. Also stuxnet hat sich dadurch ausgezeichnet, dass diese LNK-Lücke drin war, aber es hat noch vier andere Lücken benutzt, die bis dahin unbekannt waren. Bei einer ist jetzt rausgekommen, dass ein relativ penetrantes polnisches Magazin, die es von der Weile gebracht hat. Aber diese LNK-Lücke ist also wirklich relativ beeindruckend von dem Wert, dem man so Lücken zuweisen würde. Und es gab noch zwei weitere Lücken um Lokal. Wenn man auf dem Rechner jetzt so weit ist, dass man Schadcode ausführen kann, damit der sich eben Systemprivilegien besorgt und nicht nur als der User läuft, der eben den USB-Stick reingesteckt hat und gerade angemeldet war. Von der Kategorie hat stuxnet zwei gehabt. Von Lücken, mit denen es übers Netz angreifen kann, hat es zwei gehabt. Und es war mit zwei digitalen Signaturen unterschrieben. Das heißt...
Soll ich noch kurz erklären, was ein digitales Signature ist?
Genau, kommen wir gleich zu im Einzelnen, was es heißt. Aber was ich an der Stelle schon mal hinweisen wollte, das Ding ist redundant ausgelegt. Da wollte jemand sicher gehen, auch wenn jeweils die Hälfte nicht funktioniert, dass das Ding trotzdem noch Kot ausführt. Das ist schon mal ungewöhnlich für Mailware. Normalerweise, wenn ein neuer Wurm gefunden wird, dann nutzen die zwar die meisten, nutzen mehr als eine Lücke, aber das sind eigentlich immer Lücken, die schon bekannt sind. Also es ist sehr selten, dass eine Mailware gefunden wird, die eine neue Lücke ausnutzt, die noch keiner kennt. Also es hat sich so ein Ökosystem gebildet, in dem Viren und Würmer geschrieben werden, weil es nämlich Software gibt inzwischen, unter anderem von einer deutschen Firma namens Dynamics. Da geht es eben darum, dass man, wenn Microsoft eine Lücke findet und einen Patch rausbringt oder Oracle oder irgendjemand, dann kann man eben die alte Version von dem Code nehmen und die neue Version und kann sich eben angucken, was sich genau geändert hat. Und das muss eben nicht den gesamten Code angucken, sondern kann sich auf das konzentrieren, wo sich was geändert hat.
Das Wichtige dabei ist, dass man sich nicht mit der Analyse der aktuellen Mailware auseinandersetzen muss, die diese möglicherweise diese Lücke schon ausgenutzt hat, sondern halt an die Primary Source-Kanase gucken kann, was geändert wurde gegenüber der vorigen Version. Also es gibt ja zwei Möglichkeiten von neuen Lücken zu erfahren. Die eine ist, sie werden halt irgendwie publiziert, entweder in Form eines Patches oder in Form eines, keine Ahnung, Full-Disclosure-Konferenzbeitrags oder irgendwas. Und die andere ist halt, indem man mehr auseinandernimmt und guckt, welche Lücken die da drin benutzen.
Also der Punkt jedenfalls ist, dass es heute eine Sache von Stunden bis höchsten Tag ist, nachdem ein Patch draußen ist von einem Hersteller, bis klar ist, was für eine Lücke da gepatcht wurde und wahrscheinlich auch, wie man die ausnutzt.
Aber die Lücken, die stuxnet benutzt hat, die waren ja noch nicht publiziert.
Genau, das ist der Punkt. Also normalerweise ist es so, die Timeline ist so, irgendjemand findet eine Lücke, dann der Hersteller braucht ein bisschen, bis er die gefixt hat.
Und wenn derjenige ihm die Lücke sagt?
Genau, also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die Lücke dem Hersteller gesagt wird, jetzt in der Darstellung. Sag mal, ich finde eine Lücke. Als Beispiel gehe damit zum Hersteller, sag mal Apple, und sage, hier ist die Lücke. Und dann sagt Apple erstmal, ist keine Lücke. Gut, also nehme mal an, Apple fixt irgendwann die Lücke nach einem halben oder ganzen Jahr. Und dann gibt es einen Patch. Und dann dauert es einen Tag, bis die bösen Jungs wissen, wie man die Lücke ausnutzt, um einen Apple-Rechner zu kompromittieren. Und so ist es bei Windows natürlich auch. Das heißt jetzt aber, dass normalerweise die Gefahr von Würmern weitgehend vermieden werden kann, wenn man immer schön patcht. Also immer am gleichen Tag, wo die Lücken rauskommen. Und das ist eben bei stuxnet so, dass es nicht geholfen hat. Das ist eine der Sachen, die diese Mailware auszeichnet.
Weil eben die Lücken zum größten Teil noch nicht bekannt waren. Und demzufolge es weder Patches gab, noch die halt an irgendwelchen Secondary-Fixes, wie zum Beispiel Firewalls oder Antivirus-Snake-Oil oder sowas drin war.
Es ist sogar so, dass stuxnet lokal neuartige Methoden benutzt hat, wenn sie erst auf dem Rechner drauf sind, um zu vermeiden, dass sie von irgendwelchen heuristischen Antiviren gefunden werden. Also auch intern nach der Kompromittierung des Rechners ist stuxnet durchaus innovativ und hat zum Beispiel eine Methode gefunden. Also eine Sache, die die Root Kids immer ganz gerne machen oder halt Würmer, wenn sie ein System kompromittiert haben, ist, dass sie eben sich selbst verstecken natürlich. Sie wollen ja nicht, dass wenn jetzt ein Antivirus-Update rauskommt, dass sie dann sofort gefunden werden. Und was man dann eben normalerweise tut, ist, dass man versucht das System so zu ändern, dass wenn jemand dir macht, sag ich mal, ein Verzeichnis listet, dass eben bestimmte Dateien nicht gelistet werden, obwohl sie da sind. Und dafür gibt es in stuxnet eine Methode, die also auch neuartig ist und die keine bisherigen Methoden benutzt, wie sie von Antiviren gefunden werden. Also stuxnet ist auf jeder Ebene innovativ.
Ich habe es in dem Artikel als Matroschka beschrieben, die dazu dient, dieses Ding ans Ziel zu bringen, also erst mal auf den Rechner raufzukommen über den USB-Stick, der eine Schicht, nächste Schicht auf dem Rechner resident werden. Das heißt sich einnisten, dann wiederum von diesem Rechner aus weiter Computer im Netzwerk, also in dem intranet wohlgemerkt suchen. Also in dem Netzwerk, was im Inneren der angegriffenen Firma ist. Und dann gibt es noch die vierte Schicht, nämlich dafür zu sorgen, dass die eigentliche Angriffskomponente von diesem Ding ans Ziel kommt. Und das ist ein weiteres bemerkenswertes Ding bei diesem stuxnet, dass es sich dabei nämlich um einen Angriff auf eine Industrieanlage handelt. Also der...
Na, es ist überhaupt ein gezielter Angriff. Also bisherige Würmer sind eher so, dass sie erst mal versuchen zu infizieren und keine Schadensroutine mitbringen, sondern eine Steuerkomponente haben und die können dann quasi benutzt werden.
So eine Fernsteuerkomponente.
Genau, das heißt die Idee ist, so ein Wurm verbreitet sich auf möglichst vielen Rechnern mit möglichst wenig Schaden, sondern versucht erst mal nur möglichst viele Rechner unter Kontrolle zu kriegen und dann gibt es irgendeinen Kanal über den der Autor von dem Wurm dann sagen kann, jetzt spam noch mal oder jetzt sammelt doch mal Kreditkartendaten oder sowas. Das heißt normalerweise ist die Schadroutine nicht eingebaut in den Wurm, sondern die kommt danach, ist konfigurierbar. Das ist bei stuxnet nicht so, sondern das ist quasi ein All-in-one-Paket, wo gleich die Schadroutine bei war. Und die zeichnet sich eben dadurch aus, dass sie versucht, sie mit Industrie-Technik anzugreifen.
Was man vielleicht noch erwähnen sollte, der marktwirtschaftliche Grund, warum so normale kommerzielle Trojaner ihren Code nachladen, ist ja, weil es da eine Marktteilung gibt. Also zwischen Leuten, die die Rechner infizieren und Leuten, die dann hinterher diese Infektion ausnutzen. Also da gibt es so einen Markt, auf den du so Pay-Per-Infektion kaufen kannst.
Das ist wie Cloud-Computing. Also wir haben das auf dem CCC-Kongress auch immer gerne als Synonym benutzt. Das funktioniert wie bei Amazon. Man geht dann zu dem Betreiber von so einem botnetz hin und mietet sich 100.000 Rechner für eine halbe Stunde, damit die folgenden Code ausführen. Und das ist dann zum Beispiel Denial of Service, das man versucht im Webserver abzuschießen. Oder es ist halt Spam.
Oder Kreditkarten, Daten abgreifen oder so was.
Also man mietet jedenfalls die Rechner. Der Typ, der die ursprüngliche Infektion macht, der ist noch nicht gerichtet, sondern dem geht es nur darum, die Rechner zu kontrollieren, damit er das nachher vermieten kann.
Gut, aber wie gesagt, bei stuxnet war das halt anders. Da ist halt so, man muss dazu sagen, es gibt bei stuxnet viele verschiedene Varianten offensichtlich. Es wird dazu langsam über die Zeit klar, dass nicht alle offensichtlich den selben Code analysieren, sondern es halt Varianten gibt, die entweder unterschiedliche Aufgaben haben oder zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten entstanden sind. Das ist noch nicht so gänzlich klar. Im Kern ist es aber so, dass die Hauptaufgabe zu sein scheint, dass dieses Ding eine Software ans Ziel bringt, die Industrieanlagensteuerung manipuliert. Vielleicht soll man mal ein bisschen erklären, wie diese Industrieanlagensteuerung funktioniert. Wir haben überall auf der Welt jede Menge Fabriken, die im Wesentlichen computerkontrolliert sind. Das heißt, da gibt es halt so kleine Computer, die überall in dieser Fabrik sitzen. Und zum Beispiel Motordrehzahlen über Wachen und Steuern, Temperaturen über Wachen und Steuern, Gasfluss, Flüssigkeitenfluss. Alle möglichen Parameter, die so in normalen Industrieanlagen anfallen, werden über Software im Rahmen bestimmter Parameter gehalten. Und man verwendet dazu so eine Speicherprogrammierbarsteuerung. Das sind halt sehr simple Computer, so etwa auf dem Niveau von einem ausgewachsenen Taschenrechner. Und darin befindet sich nur ein sehr kleines Programm, was dafür sorgt, dass ein Input, der z. B eine Temperatur oder eine Drehzahl auslässt, ausgewertet wird oder von den vorgegebenen Parametern abweicht in bestimmter Richtung. Dann wird über einen Output gesteuert, die Drehzahl mal ein bisschen runter zu bringen oder die Temperatur ein bisschen hoch zu fahren oder den Gasfluss ein bisschen zu regeln, dergleichen Dinge mehr. Also ein verteiltes System aus vielen kleinen Computern. Jedes dieser einzelnen Dinger regelt für sich einen einzelnen Aspekt von so einer Industrieanlage.
Aber es gibt auch reine Sensoren, ne? Also das sind die meisten.
Ja klar, es gibt Regeln nicht alle nur. Die allermeisten solchen Anlagen sind sogar Sensoren. Und die sind halt in der Regel vernetzt über etwas, was man Feldbus nennt oder in neuerer Zeit viel ethernet. Also ein Profibus. Ein Profibus zum Beispiel, eines dieser Dinge. Also früher waren es halt so serielle Busse, so RS-485 basiert und heutzutage ist mehr so ethernet-technologie. Über die, die ihren derzeitigen Status, wenn sie irgendwas messen, bzw. was sie messen, aber auch Regelinformationen an eine Zentrale melden. Und da gibt es dann so eine Leitwarte und die besteht in der Regel heutzutage aus einem Windows-Computer mit einer Software, die bei der 27. WinCC heißt und auf der werden dann mit so grafischen Symbolen, die man sich dann so anordnen kann, diese Zustände visualisiert. Also zum Beispiel Füllstände von irgendwelchen Tanks oder ob ein Ventil offen oder geschlossen ist und dergleichen Dinge. Ihr habt ja bestimmt schon mal gesehen, das sind so relativ einfache standardisierte Symbole, mit denen man halt so den Fluss von Material durch so eine Industrieanlage visualisieren kann.
Also es geht nicht nur um Fertigung. Industrieanlage kann auch so was sein wie Nuklearwerk. Also wir wollen jetzt hier nicht, das sind nicht nur Atomkraftwerke.
Nee, nee, überhaupt nicht. Also die Atomkraftwerke sind wahrscheinlich die wenigsten davon, sondern die allermeisten sind halt sowas, was es sich etwa raffentun oder auch normale Energieanlagen, also zum Beispiel so diese Trafostationen, die halt überall rumstehen, die werden halt auch von solchen Skalerkomponenten gesteuert. Das ist gerade das Wort erwähnt, Skala, also ist der angesächsische Begriff für diese Industrie-Automatisierungsgeschichten. Und interessant ist daran, dass die allermeisten Anlagen, ich hab mal eine besichtigen können, die ich jetzt mal nicht namentlich erwähne, da ist es halt so, dass die Anzeigen manueller Instrumente, auf denen man noch sehen kann, also wenn man da hinläuft zum Beispiel zu einer Raffinerie, und man möchte gerne wissen, wie die Temperatur ist, jetzt in so einer Reaktorkolonne, vor der man steht, da gibt es nur noch extrem wenige manuelle Instrumente, die sind im Wesentlichen nur noch für die Werksfeuerwehr da, also wenn irgendwas schief geht, dass die, wenn die vor Ort sind, sehen können, was los ist, und die Leute, die da rumlaufen, um halt irgendwie zu gucken und zu testen und so, die haben halt so Handheld-Trends, die sich halt da reinstecken, wahrscheinlich mittlerweile über WLAN.
Ja, WLAN. Also zwei Anekdoten an der Stelle. Erstens ist das gut so, dass es nicht mehr lauter manuelle Sachen gibt, denn es gab nämlich das Problem, bei einigen Unfällen, die man danach analysiert hat, dass es widersprüchliche Anzeigen dann gab und dass die Leute vor Ort dadurch mehr verwirrt waren und länger gebraucht haben und dass es überhaupt erst zu dem Unfall gekommen ist, weil die halt verwirrt waren und nicht wussten, was sie jetzt konkret tun sollen. Und die andere Anekdote geht um WLAN. Da geht es nämlich darum, in US-Atomkraftwerken haben wir das erzählt, das sind von jemanden, der sich in den USA auskennt. Und der hat mir erzählt, dass die Strategie von Greenpeace und ähnlichen Organisationen gegen Atomkraft im Wesentlichen ist, die Gefahren hochzureden, damit die Anforderungen, die regulativen Anforderungen an Atomkraftwerke und die Komponenten sehr hoch werden. Und dann muss man praktisch jeden Scheiß, den man installiert, erst mal zertifizieren lassen. Und die Kosten sind dann so weit, dass so ein ethernetkabel pro Meter irgendwie 10.000 Dollar kostet. Von legen bis planen, bis irgendwie alles updaten, mit den ganzen Behörden reden. Und dadurch ist es eben für die Leute am Ende billiger, wenn sie sich da WLAN hinstellen, obwohl es ja die unsichere Technologie ist. Das heißt, da haben wir uns quasi selbst in den Fuß geschossen. Und WLAN, also an der Stelle könnten wir vielleicht durchaus mal empfehlen, auf der CeBIT rumzulaufen und sich das mal anzusehen. Also das denken wir uns jetzt nicht aus, sondern da gibt es halt Halle 1, ist das glaube ich, wo die ganzen langweiligen grauen Kisten stehen, an denen wir immer vorbeilaufen, weil die so langweilig aussehen. Also das ist durchaus nicht nur langweilig, sondern es lohnt sich das mal aus der Nähe anzugucken.
Ich glaube, auf dieser CeBIT, also auf der nächsten CeBIT, wird Halle 1 voll sein. Wird es da voll sein bei den ganzen Industrial-Control-Geschichten, da werden die ganzen Hacker rumlaufen und fragen, ob sie halt da mal...
Kann man mal ein Testgerät haben. Das wollten wir eigentlich sowieso mal machen, oder? Wollen wir das mal machen? Sie werden uns fragen, ob sie uns nicht eine Teststellung geben zum Kongress. Brauen sie uns noch mal ein kleines Kraftwerk hin?
Na, ich habe eigentlich ja versucht mal die Hersteller von diesen Anlagen und auch die Betreiber von diesen Anlagen aufzufordern, dass sie mal zum Kongress kommen und uns erklären, warum es eigentlich sicher ist. Warum es eigentlich sicher ist, da kommen wir vielleicht später noch mal dazu. Gut, aber in das für Kontrollgeschichten, worauf ich hinaus wollte, war ja, die Kontrolle über diese Anlage findet ja eigentlich nur noch statt in der Leitwarte. Das heißt, auf dem Computerbildschirm in der Leitwarte werden diese Werte gesehen, selbst wenn man rausläuft ins Feld, sieht man halt nur noch ein paar Parameter.
Und das ist virtuell?
Das ist halt komplett virtuell. Das heißt, die haben halt ein reines Abbild, was durch den Computer vermittelt ist. Das heißt, man anfängt dieses Abbild zu manipulieren.
Und der hat es auch nicht direkt, sondern über Netzwerk.
Also wenn dieses Abbild manipuliert wird, dann verliert der Betreiber die Kontrolle über die Anlage. Und genau da setzt halt dieser Angriff auf diese Industriesteuerung an. Also was wir bisher wissen, und wir wissen noch nicht alles über diesen Teil der Software von stuxnet, ist, dass da gezielt bestimmte Parameter innerhalb einer bestimmten Industrieanlage manipuliert werden. Und das weist halt auch nochmal auf einen sehr wesentlichen Aspekt hin. Dieses ganze Delivery-System, also was dafür sorgt, dass dieses Ding ans Ziel kommt, hat erst mal noch keine... Es ist nicht besonders spezifisch. Der innere Teil aber, der, der dann die Anlage angreifen soll, wird erst aktiv, wenn er bestimmte Anlagenkonfigurationen sieht. Das heißt also, wenn er Parameter sieht und Dateien sieht auf diesem Computer, die ihm vorher bekannt sind. Und man kann aus der Software sehr gut ersehen, dass diejenigen, die dieses Ding programmiert haben, sehr präzise wussten, was auf dieser Anlage läuft. Also welche Software darauf läuft, welche Konfigurationen darauf laufen, wie es genau da aussieht. Also so genau, dass man eigentlich davon ausgehen kann, dass die einen Abzug von der Software hatten, die auf dieser Anlage läuft.
Also man sollte dazu sagen, dass das keine von der Stange Technologie ist, sondern dass jede Installation komplett custom ist. Man kann zwar die Teile alle von der Stange kaufen, aber wie die jetzt zusammengebastelt sind und wer da mit wem redet und wo der Bus liegt, das ist alles komplett anders in jeder Anlage. Und was jetzt diese Malware tut, ist, dass sie quasi weiß, welche Komponente mit welcher ID welche Botschaft verschicken kann. Und das deutet eben darauf hin, dass sie entweder jemanden vor Ort hatten, der ihnen das alles sagen konnte, oder dass sie zumindest anderweitig genau wussten, was da abgeht. Vielleicht die die Pläne gesehen haben oder sowas.
Also wir können eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass jetzt aus der derzeitlichen Reihenfolge von dem, der gleich zu kommen, dass vermutlich ein Überläufer ihnen diese Daten gebracht hat. Also zu dem System, womit wir eigentlich auch schon zum Ziel kommen.
Also wir sollten vielleicht erst mal noch historisch, gibt es nämlich einen Vergleich, warum überhaupt alle von Sabotage reden. Das könnte ja auch gutartig sein. Es gibt einen sehr berühmten Fall von Industrie-Sabotage, nämlich die Siberian Pipeline-Sabotage. Das war 1982. Da haben nämlich die Sowjets in Amerika Kontrolltechnologie für Ölpipelines gekauft. Und die Amerikaner haben das gemerkt und haben ihnen dann gezielt sabotierte Software untergejubelt.
Na die haben versucht, also sie haben als erstes unterbunden, dass sie diese Technologie in den USA kaufen konnten. Haben dann gesehen, dass die Sowjets versuchen, die in Kanada zu kriegen und haben dann diese Firma in Kanada benutzt, um ihnen manipulierte Software unterzujubeln für diese Gaspipelans. Also diese Gaspipelans sind halt riesige Anlagen, die erstrecken sich über 100 oder 1000 Kilometer. Na gerade in Sibirien, das sind ja unglaubliche......Distanzen, ja. Und die haben regelmäßige, so genannte Verdichterstationen. Diese Verdichterstationen sind ziemlich interessante Dinge, weil da geht ja in der Regel keine Stromleitung hin. Das heißt also, die gewinnen aus dem Gas, was sie da lokal haben. Also was in dieser Leitung drin ist, betreiben sie eine Turbine.
Ach und generieren vor Ort den Strom?
Mit der Turbine betreiben sie die Pumpe, die dann den Gasdruck wieder hochbringt. Also das sind halt so Self-Content-Ligere, die du halt einfach wirklich in die Teigast stellen kannst und die dann halt automatisch halt den Druck regeln. Die sind halt auch nicht zentral angebunden. Also das ist halt so, dass die Russen machen halt sehr viel mit Richtfunkstrecken. Und da passiert es halt auch schon mal, dass so eine Richtfunkstrecke ausfällt, zum Beispiel, weil die Antennen vereisen. Also dann sehen die halt eine Weile nichts, bis irgendwie die Antennen enteisten. Also diese Gasfahrtdichterstationen sind halt darauf ausgelegt, halt möglichst autonom zu arbeiten, aber haben natürlich eigentlich auch eine vernetzungskomponente. Das Gerücht war nun, beziehungsweise mittlerweile kam es nach diesem Fahrwehrreport, den wir verlinken sollten, die Fahrwehrreportauswertung sollten wir verlinken in den Hinweisen, haben die offensichtlich dafür gesorgt, dass die Pumpstationen in einer Art und Weise eine wellenförmige Bewegung des Drucks erzeugt haben, dass es zu einer stehenden Druckwelle in der Leitung kam und dann halt ein Überdruck entstand und die Leitung geborsten ist und dann dementsprechend explodiert ist.
Drei Kilotonnen TNT, das Springstoff in Köln, was sie da erzeugt haben, das ist schon nicht ohne.
Ja und es gibt ja diese hübsche Geschichte in den Nomaden von einem von diesen Typen, die da beteiligt waren, dass sie wohl extra zu der Zeit, wo sie es erwartet haben, jemand ins NORAD geschickt haben, also der North American Air Defense Network.
Angeblich konnte man das auf den Überwachungs-Satelliten sehen, weil die Explosionen so groß waren.
Weil sie halt eine fette IR-Signatur, so eine Infraport-Signatur über Sibirien gesehen haben, in der Gegend, wo sie bisher keine Raketensilos gesehen haben. Und damit da niemand irgendwie auf die falsche Idee kommt, da könnte jetzt gerade ein Raketenstart aus einem bisher unbekannten Raketensilo erfolgt sein, haben sie gesagt, derle.
Nö, nö, das waren wir.
Das soll so. Gut, also was wir sehen, es gibt halt schon eine längliche Geschichte der Amerikaner, die halt diese Sabotage von generischer Industrie-Technik ja schon eine Weile betreiben. Und im Fall des Iran, dem wahrscheinlich ein Ziel vom stuxnet, gibt es da auch schon sehr umfangreiche Dokumentationen darüber, dass es da ein kleines Dienstprogramm gegen das Nuklearprogramm des Iran gibt.
Wo auch richtig Kohle reingeflossen ist. Also erklärte Ziele sind a, das Nuklearprogramm und b, ein Regierungswechsel. Also das ist, haben die Amis auch völlig offen betrieben und da, also ich glaube, dreistellige Millionenbeträge reingepumpt, also auch nicht ohne. Wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie viele Leute die da in so einer Abteilung haben können, dann kommt schon was zusammen pro Kopf.
Also gibt da eine lange Geschichte jetzt von Überläufern, die mehr oder minder freiwillig dann irgendwie aus Mekka nicht mehr zurückgekommen sind oder aus der Türkei auf jeden Fall abgebogen sind und dergleichen Dinge mehr und dann halt in den USA gelandet sind. Da ist jetzt auch einer irgendwie Weiträumig verfahren. Unterm nachwürdigem Umstände wieder zurückgekommen. Also die, wir wissen also, dass es eine Menge Möglichkeiten gegeben hätte, für die Amis an diese Daten zu kommen. Es ist auch bekannt, dass die Israelis ein umfangreiches Programm zusammen mit den Amis fahren gegen das iranische Atomprogramm und da auch Überläufer rekrutieren und Agenten rekrutieren und dergleichen Ding mehr. Also wir wissen, dass es da halt so eine Programme gibt. Nun ist in stuxnet, also in dem Virus, in der Analyse, sind so ein paar Daten drin, die darauf hinweisen, dass tatsächlich das Ziel der Iran gewesen sein könnte. Zum einen gibt es mehrere Berichte darüber, dass zumindest eine der Varianten im Januar 2009 aufhören sollte, sich zu verbreiten. Wo es die interessante Koinzidenz gibt, dass im Januar 2009 George W. Bush seine Amtszeit beendet hat.
Und dass da die Autorisierung möglicherweise abläuft.
Möglicherweise ist die Autorisierung für die Programme zu dem Zeitpunkt abgelaufen. Dann gibt es noch andere Daten, die so auf Mai und Juni 2009 hinlaufen. Und wir haben Hinweise darauf, und zwar in Form einer Nachricht von Wikileaks, die gepostet wurde, dass im Frühjahr 2009 ein größerer Nuklear-Aunfall in der Anreichungsanlage in Natanz stattgefunden haben soll. Und daraufhin der Chef des iranischen Atomprogramms zurückgetreten wurde. Und danach auch nicht mehr so richtig gesehen wurde. Dann gibt es noch einen weiteren Hinweis, nämlich dass der Output der Zentrifugen, die von der Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde überwacht werden, in Natanz etwa genau im Mai, Juni 2009 dramatisch eingeknickt ist. Das heißt also, da ist der Output gefallen.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch einen kleinen Überblick geben. Natanz ist eine Anreicherungsanlage.
Genau, ich erkläre mal kurz, was man so braucht für ein Atomprogramm. Man fängt an mit Uran-Erz. Das wird aufbereitet zu so nach einem Yellow Cake. Das ist also ein angereichtes Uran-Erz, in dem einfach nur mehr Uran drin ist.
Na ja, eigentlich Anreichung an der Stelle, heißt, denen den regulären Stein raus fehlt.
Genau, da wird nichts irgendwie chemisch gemacht. Also die Anreichung ist schon chemisch, aber da wird noch keine Isotopentrennung vorgenommen. Man braucht ja, um Bomben zu bauen, braucht man ja nur eines der Uran-Iso-Tope. Und diese Trennung vorzunehmen, ist halt dann...
Und auch für Reaktoren brauchst du nun das eine.
Genau, also um Atomspaltung vorzunehmen. Aber um dahin zu kommen, dass man überhaupt diese Isotopen-Anreichungen vornehmen kann, muss man das erstmal in einer Form kriegen, die für diese Prozesse geeignet ist. Und der Schritt ist halt zuerst dieses Yellow Cake, das ist halt so ein strahlendes gelbes Pulver. Und wir erinnern uns vielleicht, das hatten wir einmal in der North News Show, diese Geschichte mit diesem... Aus diesem lustigen, aus dieser Anlage in der Tanz, nämlich genau, entschuldigung, in Isafar. Dort, was dort stattfindet, ist, da wird das Yellow Cake über einen chemischen Prozess in sogenanntes Uranhexaflorid umgewandelt. Das ist eine extrem ekelige Substanz, die wird so bei 130-140 Grad glaube ich gasförmig. Es gibt eine kurze Flüssigphase, die ist abhängig vom Druck. Und dann kann sie halt durch Gaszentrifugen angereichert werden. Und diese Substanz, wenn sie gasförmig ist, ist halt extrem ätzend. Man kann sie also eigentlich nur durch Aluminiumleitungen und Aluminiumzentrifugen und dergleichen Dinge mehr leiten, weil sich auf der Oberfläche des Aluminiums dann sofort eine Verbindung bildet, die halt vor weiteren Angriff schützt. Aber ansonsten ist das Zeug so ätzend, dass es sich durch alle durchfrisst. Das ist halt wirklich hochgradig widerlich. Also radioaktiv, giftig und ätzend. Also wenn man sich mal was wünschen darf.
Genau das, was man mal mit Industrie-Spionage explodieren lassen will.
Nicht Spionage, Industrie-Sabotage. Also diese Anreichung in Natanz ist also angewiesen auf den Output der Anlage in Isafran. Das heißt, was da stattfindet, ist diese Yellow Cake wird zu Uranhexaflorid, wird in Stahlzylinder verpackt. Die Stahlzylinder werden in die Anreichungsanlage geschoben. Da wird da wieder das Gas draus gemacht. Das Gas wird in den Zentrifugen geleitet. In diesen Zentrifugen, die laufen an extrem hoher Geschwindigkeit. Das sind einige Zehntausend Umdrehungen pro Minute. Darin bildet sich dann ein Wirbel aus diesem Gas, in dem die schweren Isotope außen sind und die leichteren Isotope innen.
Aber die Unterschiede sind so minimal, dass man da mehr als einen Schritt braucht.
Ja, man braucht mehrere tausend Schritte in der Regel. Die Zentrifugen werden in Kraskaden hintereinander geschaltet, wo der etwas angereichertere Anteil des schwereren Isotopes bzw. des leichteren Isotopes innen jeweils die nächste Kraskadenstufe geleitet wird, sodass an jeder Stufe nur so ein bisschen ausgefiltert wird. Am Ende reden wir auch nur von Anreichungen im Prozentbereich.
Also für Atomkraftwerke braucht man so 10 Prozent, für Bomben so 80 Prozent.
Ja, für Bomben braucht man halt signifikant mehr, je nach Konstruktionsprinzip der Bombe. Diese Zentrifugenden sind halt ziemlich empfindliche Dinge. Also wenn man möchte, dass einem die nicht um die Ohren fliegen, dann darf man die zum Beispiel nicht mit bloßen Händen anfassen, weil alleine ein Handabdruck auf der einen Seite von dem Rotationskörper führt zu einer Unwucht, die dazu führt, dass einem das Ding irgendwann um die Ohren fliegt bzw. die Lager ausschlägt. Das heißt, diese Hochgeschwindigkeitszentrifugen ist eine echt eigene Wissenschaft, womit man mit höchster Präzision fertigen muss und halt auch in der Verarbeitung und im Handling von diesen Dingern wirklich sehr, sehr vorsichtig sein muss. Und also meine Theorie ist ja eher, dass die nicht wie bisher behauptet wurde Bushir, also das Atomkraftwerk, der Iraner angegriffen werden sollte mit diesem stuxnet-wurm, sondern eben genau diese Zentrifugenanlage oder möglicherweise hat die Anreicherung in Isfahan, die steht interessanterweise auch seit Frühjahr 2009 still. Also im April 2009, da kann man suchen, gibt es noch eine lustige Presseführung, von der es eine hübsche Galerie von Reutersbildern gibt.
Die wir auch gebraucht haben für den Fondantrückblick, weil man da unter anderem so einen Typ sehen konnte, der da mit Klopapier unterm Arm.
Küchenrolle.
Küchenrolle, Küchenrolle, unterm Arm. Und als Einziger in der großen Menge ohne Mundschutz, dass die Tonnen irgendwie gehändelt hat. Also das war sehr witzig.
Material mit einem auffällig gelben Pröver, das ist wohl wahrscheinlich das Yellow Cake.
Das sieht so aus wie den Homer Simpson.
Genau, das hat er deutlich, Homer Simpson. Also ihr kennt das ja, mit Homer Simpson, der der Vorspann da noch was aus dem Atomkraftwerk mitgenommen hat, was in grün glüht. Gut, also auch diese Anlagen im Iran sind mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit halt betrieben, eben mit solchen Siemens Industrial Control System. Es gibt da hinreichend Hinweise darauf, dass der Iran über die Zeit etliche von diesen Step 7, so heißen diese Anlagen, Version 300 gekauft hat und auch Module gekauft hat. Erst neulich wieder gab es eine Geschichte, dass irgendwie in irgendeinem Freihafenlager in Dubai oder so ein größerer Posten von dem Zeug hochgegangen ist. Ich glaube, in den letzten Jahren war es den die Dubai aufgehalten haben, den sich die Iraner irgendwo besorgt haben auf dem Weltmarkt und der ja möglicherweise auch eben ins Iranisch-Hortum-Programm gehen sollte. Kann natürlich auch sein, dass sie damit einfach nur eine Chemiefabrik steuern wollten, eine Düngemittelfabrik oder keine Ahnung.
Also warum ich jetzt hier mal auf Klärwerk rumhauere, das ist, was Sie, Mäns, in Ihrer offiziellen Presseerklärung gesagt haben. Sie haben gesagt, ja, Topkraftwerk ist ja gar nicht klar. Das wird ja heute Klärwerken benutzt und das wollen wir alle nicht so.
Ja, lustigerweise ist aber genau Boucher, weswegen ja diese Initialtheorie entstanden ist, dass Boucher das Ziel dieser Geschichte gewesen sein könnte, ist eine der Beispielkonfigurationen, wenn man mal danach googelt, dann gibt es von Siemens eine Anleitung, so für seinen Simulator, für seine Anlage, seine Simatik-Steuerungsanlage.
Da gibt es so ein Feldreferenzimplementierung und da ist nochmal, ich glaube, was war das?
26 ist Boucher.
Also in das jeden Fall sind PDF auf der Siemens-Webseite.
Ich hoffe, irgendjemand hat es mal gemürret.
Also dieses S7 Zeug, das ist keine restrikte Technology sozusagen. Dann könnt ihr mal, wenn ihr Bock habt, mal eben bei eBay klicken und Siemens S7 eingeben und da finden wir da also diverse Module. Wer genug Kleingeld hat und zum Kongress ein bisschen basteln will, da ist man so ab 250, 300 Euro ist man dabei.
Genau, mal eine Industrial-Control-Kaffeemaschine bauen zum Beispiel. Ordentliche Temperatur- und Drucküberwachung, das wäre doch mal toll.
Ja, will man eigentlich haben.
Will man eigentlich haben, immer ein bisschen Lernen am System. Gut, der Code, der dann diese im Inneren von diesem stuxnet-wohnungen lauert, sollte eben genauso eine Industrial-Control-Anlage manipulieren. Und der spielt da zumindest der Teil des Codes, der bisher bekannt ist, da gibt es auch noch Teile des Codes, die bisher immer noch verschlüsselt sind und von dem man noch nicht weiß, was er tut. Der Code sollte einzelne Parameter daran manipulieren, Timer-Values manipulieren und aber offensichtlich auch gucken, welche Notes in der Anlage noch infiziert sind über so einen Hard-Beat-Ping. Also zumindest einer der Analysen, von denen mir berichtet wurde, sieht so aus.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch sagen, was eigentlich diese Speicher-Sachen da konkret tun.
Die Speicher programmieren wir an Steuerung?
Genau.
Also es handelt sich dabei um, wie gesagt, relativ simple Computer, die in einem so nach einem Bytecode programmiert werden.
Wir haben schon gesagt, Komplexität ist ungefähr ein Taschenrechner. Wenn man ein bisschen in der Siemens Produktfamilie rumklickt, die die Specks sind, also vielleicht nicht alle, aber viele davon sind offen, dann kommt man so auf Größenordnung bis 32K RAM sind da drin. Also da hat man eine Vorstellung davon, was das für kräftige Computer sind. Und es gibt Screenshots von der Entwicklungsumgebung, mit der man die Teile programmiert. Und das sieht so ein bisschen aus, wie wir lernen jetzt mal Assembler. Also das ist durchaus, also ich meine, wenn man noch nie Assembler gemacht hat, wahrscheinlich schwarze Magie. Aber für Leute, die schon mal eine CPU von Namen programmiert haben, sieht das jetzt nicht mysteriös aus.
Und das Interessante daran ist jetzt, dass der Code in diesem stuxnet-wohnen, der benutzt zum einen Teile von Code, die offensichtlich aus so einem Programmiertool stammen. Und zum anderen benutzt er aber auch Teile des Codes, die direkt unten auf der CPU unter Umgebung des Bytecodes, also auf der eigentlichen Maschine, die hinter dieser Steuerung sitzt, arbeitet. Und die eben dementsprechend auch nicht gesehen werden kann mit diesem Programmiertool. Und nimmt da Manipulationen vor, die halt so nicht sichtbar sind. Selbst wenn man anfängt, den Code auf diesem Ding zu analysieren, gibt es da halt diese sogenannte Routekit-Funktion, die dafür sorgt, dass man das A nicht entfernen kann. Also man steckt ein neues Modul rein oder programmiert es auf eben dieser niedrigen Ebene neu oder...
Oder man geht direkt dran. Normalerweise würde man eben nicht direkt rangehen, sondern man würde die Software von Siemens benutzen. Und die kommuniziert mit den speichern programmierbaren Controllern über eine DLL, also ein Programmmodul auf dem Windows-Rechner. Und genau diese DLL wird eben von stuxnet ersetzt. Also die alte wird unbenannt und dann gibt es eine neue und die beruft eigentlich für alle Funktionen, die Siemens-DLL auf. Aber tut eben in einigen Fällen zwei, drei Sachen wie manipuliert eben die Daten, die abgeladen, hochgeladen werden und die Daten, die runterkommen, so dass es für die Software so aussieht, als würde genau die Daten, die man hochgespielt hat, auch wieder runterkommen. Und man sieht also nicht, dass da irgendwas infiziert ist. Das ist schon relativ clever. Nun gibt es verschiedene Klassen von diesen speicher programmierbaren Controllern. Es gibt also, das war einer der Einwände bei dem FAZ-Artikel. Das ist ja in deutschen Kernkraftwerken gibt es da besondere Anforderungen. Sicherheitsniveaus und das ist sogar europaweit festgeschrieben. Und da stehen dann zum Beispiel Sachen drin, wie dass man den Programmspeicher bei so einem Controller nicht mal eben überschreiben darf, sondern dass es nur erlaubt oder die Hardware lässt es nur zu, wenn vor Ort jemand einen Schlüssel umgelegt hat an dem Controller. Und das ist durchaus eine sinnvolle Sache, aber der Iran ist eben a. nicht Teil der EU, b. interessiert sie auch nicht, ob der TÜV das zulassen würde und c. haben die auch nicht die Wahl, was für Komponenten sie da kaufen, sondern sie nehmen eben, was sie kriegen können. Die sind immerhin unter einem Embargo. Und das heißt eben in der Praxis, dass sie da wahrscheinlich eben nicht die High-End-Sachen gekriegt haben, sondern eher die Sachen, die man auch auf eBay kriegt. Und also man kann in dem stuxnet kurz sehen, welche Arten von Controller der angreift. Und es sind halt genau die Billig-Schrotti-Controller.
Nein, die sind nicht Schrotti, sind halt entweder alt oder billig.
Naja, also das ist ja quasi nach Siemens Definition alt und Schrotti.
Und diese Einwendung, dass es halt in Deutschland überhaupt nicht gehen könnte, so bringen wir uns wieder zu diesem Punkt zurück. Ich würde gerne mal ein Detail erklärt bekommen, warum es in Deutschland nicht funktioniert, also wie halt es tatsächlich aussieht. Wir haben so ein bisschen recherchiert.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir euch nicht glauben würden, liebe Franz-Werk-Aufwähler. Wir würden gerne, dass ihr ein Techie schickt, und uns mal die Details erklärt, damit wir ruhig schlafen können.
Also wir haben ein bisschen recherchiert und eine der Sachen, die wir fanden, war im Kraftwerk. Ich glaube, es war Unterweser. Da gab es im Bundpapier von einem dieser Energieversorger, so wir sind toll, gab es einen Bericht über die Umrüstung mit der Kühlwasserpumpanlage, also das Sekundärkreislauf. Der pumpt halt aus der Weser das Wasser raus und muss halt entsprechend die Kraftfestleistung regeln, je nachdem, wie warm das Wasser der Weser ist und wie viel Wasser da ist. Und wenn halt gerade im Sommer wenig Wasser da ist und das Weser, was ohnehin warm ist, dann kann halt relativ wenig Kühlleistung darüber abgeführt werden, also muss die Sache runter geregelt werden. Dieser Bericht war von einem Umbau im Jahr 2003 und da wurden Siemens S5, also Step 5, der Vorgänger von dem stuxnet-reden, verwendet. Und das ist halt noch so die beige Phase der Informatik. Also wir haben ja so diese S7, sind halt noch so diese schwarzen...
Das sind noch die Endlos-Drucker, Nadel-Drucker.
Ja, also da reden wir halt noch von einer echt anderen Ära so. Die aber offensichtlich, die Teile gibt es immer noch, ich glaube die werden auch noch eine Weile laufen, weil die sind noch an so vielen Stellen verbaut.
Vor allem sind die auch billig.
Und da kann es halt sein, also wie gesagt, da war es halt offensichtlich so, also zumindest ist es so zwischen den Zeilen zu lesen, dass in deinem Unterwesen diese S5-Controller verbaut wurden, weil das gesamte Kraftwerk auf diesen S5-Controllern beruht und sie sich da keine neue Serie reinholen wollten. Und zu den S5-Controllern wissen wir jetzt noch nicht so viel, also wie die Programmierung funktioniert, ob es mittlerweile auf Feldboss entfällt, wie viel die es dazu gibt.
Die gibt es aber auch auf Ebay. Wenn ihr ein bisschen Freizeit und Kohle übrig habt, dann kauft euch doch bei Ebay ein paar coole Komponenten und zeigt uns auf dem Kongress, wie man die programmiert.
Mit eurer Kaffeemaschine oder was auch immer.
Ja, also eine der lustigeren Sachen war, in diesem stuxnet-umfeld haben sich ja auch diverse Kraftwerksbetreiber und Siemens genötigt gesehen, abwiegelnde Beruhigungs-PR in Richtung Bevölkerung zu schicken. Und eine davon war eben, nein, Windows käme uns nie in die Nähe von irgendwelchen Atomkraftwerksleitstellen und Steuerblatt. Das ist alles undenkbar, dass das Windows ist.
Und da gibt es eigentlich nicht so viele Alternativen.
Da gibt es nicht viele Alternativen. Also praktisch der gesamte Markt ist Windows. Siemens sowieso, die meisten Konkurrenten auch, zumindest die größeren, sind Windows inzwischen. Man kann natürlich ein bisschen in die Vergangenheit laufen. Dann hat man DOS-Systeme, dass ist nicht klar, ob das besser ist als wenn wir da Windows hätten. Und es gibt eben, also erstens, wenn wir jetzt hören, dass die Kühlung unter Windows gemacht wird, das ist ja schon eine kritische Komponente von so einem Kraftwerk.
Bei diesem S5 ist nicht klar, ob es Windows ist. Das war nicht klar. Also diese S5 ist ja erstmal nur eine Serie von diesen...
Achso, da waren nur die tatsächlichen Controller?
Genau, da waren leider keine Windungscreenshots zu sehen. Also ich weiß nicht genau, wie die da tatsächlich programmiert werden. Es kann sein, dass noch BS2000 zum Einsatz kommt. Also, naja, damit wird auch deine Rente berechnet, die du nicht kriegst.
Ja, prima. Unsere Atomkraftwerke sind so sicher wie unsere Renten.
Da wollen wir nicht spekulieren. Da warten wir mal drauf, ob einer von den Energieversorgern unser Angebot anhat und uns zu erklären, warum es bei uns sicher ist. Wie gesagt, das würden wir doch sehr begrüßen, weil dann schlafen wir auch besser.
Und wir hören auch sofort auf, euch zu bashen, wenn ihr uns erklärt habt, warum es sicher ist.
Genau. Gut. Natürlich sind die Spekulationen zu stuxnet noch weiter in die Richtung, wer war es denn? Der Iran hat zugegeben, dass er Opfer ist von stuxnet. Das war gestern.
Was ja noch nicht heißt, dass es auf den Iran gezielt wurde. Das sagen wir hauptsächlich, weil es zwei Analysen von Symantec und von ESET gibt, zwei prominente Antiviren-Hersteller. Das an sich ist schon eine interessante Sache, denn eigentlich gibt es ein Handelsimbargo gegen den Iran. Das heißt, Iraner dürfen gar nicht diese Antiviren kaufen können. Auf der anderen Seite ist das Urheberrecht im Iran auch so, dass Urheberrecht nur auf im Iran gemachte Werke gilt. Das heißt, es ist völlig legal, sich US-Software zu kopieren im Iran. Das heißt, wir können mal davon ausgehen, dass alle Antiviren, die im Iran deployed sind, Raubkopien sind.
Außer die aus Belarusland.
Außer, na gut, diese, ja, okay. Also ESET kommt aus der Slowakei, glaube ich.
Nein, Bratislava, Slowakei.
Ja, also gut, das ist EU.
Gut, also...
Aber jedenfalls, dass es überhaupt Statistiken gibt, fand ich schon mal interessant an der Stelle. Denn wenn das alles Raubkopien sind, da würde man ja denken, dass die Hersteller dann auch da irgendwie versuchen, die aus der Ferne auszuschalten oder so, wenn sie da kein Geld für kriegen. Aber das stimmt nicht. Und wenn sie es getan hätten, würden sie sich auch in den Arsch beißen jetzt, denn dann hätten sie Statistiken nicht. Also es gibt Statistiken. Und die sagen, 60 Prozent der Infektionen sind im Iran und der nächste größte ist Singapur.
Indien, Malaysia und Russland.
Es gibt auch Infektionen in den USA und in Deutschland. Aber es ist eben so, dass dieser Code, nachdem er die Rechner infiziert, sehr genau guckt, ob er jetzt auf dem anzugreifenden Werk läuft und wenn nicht, macht er halt nichts.
Genau.
Insofern, das ist übrigens ein echtes Alleinstellungsmerkmal von stuxnet. Nicht, dass er nichts macht, sondern, dass die Software wirklich bemüht ist, nicht zu crashen. Normalerweise ist Mailware so eine Sache, selbst jetzt, wo das ein Geschäftsmodell ist, ist es so eine Sache, naja, wenn es crasht, dann crasht es eben. Also wir erinnern uns an einen Würmer, wo dann ein Fenster hochkommt, dass man jetzt rebooten muss. Also das ist natürlich ein Giveaway, so was. Wenn so was kommt, dann hat man ja einen Indiz dafür, dass man infiziert worden ist. Und bei stuxnet ist es sogar so, dass die Kernel-Module Fehlerprüfungen machen. Das heißt, wenn irgendwie irgendwas intern fehlschlägt, war gerade kein Speicher im System. Das sind Sachen, die machen nicht mal kommerzielle Treiber vollständig. Ja, also gerade von Firmen wie Realtek, wo jetzt die eine digitale Signatur herkam, selbst bei denen, Leute, die für ihren Lebensunterhalt Treiber schreiben, sind da normalerweise ziemlich sloppy. Aber in stuxnet kann man sehen, dass die Leute sich bemüht haben, unter keinen Umständen das System in einem unstabilen Zustand zu hinterlassen. Das heißt, lieber nicht infizieren, als erkannt werden. Und das ist eine Sache, das deutet darauf hin, dass das eben nicht von ein paar Roadies gemacht wurde, die sich dann ein paar Euro verdienen wollen.
Also einer der Leute, die in der Analyse arbeiten, sagte zu mir, dass die Qualität der Software eigentlich eher vergleichbar ist mit dem, was man so bei Flugzeugen findet. Also wenn man halt Systeme baut, die tatsächlich ein gewisses Schadenspotenzial haben, als mit dem, was man so ein normaler, kommerzieller Software findet. Anderer sagte zu mir, ja, also dieses stuxnet, dieses Gesamtding ist halt was, was man baut als Nationalstaat, wenn man irgendwie als andere Alternative hat, in den Krieg zu ziehen.
Da sind sich eigentlich alle Analysen im Moment einig, dass das deutlich so aussieht, als wäre da ein Nationalstaat beteiligt und nicht, sag mal mal, eine Firma, die was zeigen will oder so.
Nee, also, denk mal, die Breite an Wissen, die da notwendig war, ist beeindruckend. Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall ein Team gewesen, was schon eine gewisse Zeit trainiert hat und halt schon eine gewisse Planung hatte und wahrscheinlich eine gewisse Übung hatte. Es gibt ja, wie schon erwähnt, mehrere Varianten von diesem Ding. Eine der Theorien momentan ist, dass sozusagen eine erste Variante eingesetzt wurde, um überhaupt an die Daten zu kommen, die dann halt wiederum benutzt wurden, um dieses Industrial-Control-Ding zu machen, also um halt diese Industrieanlage anzugreifen. Andere Theorien sind halt, dass der originale Virus irgendjemand in die Hand gefallen ist, der ihn dann modifiziert hat für seine eigenen Zwecke. Also da gibt es mehrere Varianten, die die Hauptverdächtigen, die in der Presse momentan diskutiert werden, sind halt natürlich die USA und Israel, die halt beide im Klandestinen-Programme gegen den Iran fahren mit großem Aufwand und wo auch niemand irgendwie irgendeine Art von Zweifel hat, dass die im Zweifel über die entsprechenden Kapazitäten und die Teams verfügen würden, wenn sie denn wollten. Also da glaube ich, gerade momentan die beiden Hauptverdächtigen. Ich glaube, so in der Reverse-Engineer-Szene ist momentan Israel die populärste Theorie.
In den USA, lustigerweise, scheint der Konsens zu sein, dass es die NSA war. Also das ist schon ganz witzig eigentlich, weil der Rest der Welt ist nicht im Grunde einig, dass es Israel gewesen sein wird.
Vielleicht waren es so beide, kann natürlich auch sein, dass das so war.
Das kann natürlich sein, na klar.
Also gerade die Israelis haben ja doch Gerüchten zuvor, wie relativ viele lokale Assets im Iran und dementsprechend möglicherweise waren sie in der Lage dafür zu sagen, dass die initialen US-B-Sticks dahin kamen, wo der Angriff mit möglichst Erfolg versprechend ist und die Distanz zum Ziel nicht so groß ist.
Was ja schon auch eine lustige Ironie ist in der Geschichte, denn die Amerikaner hatten ja durchaus Probleme mit gebrauchten US-B-Sticks, die sie da in Afghanistan gekauft haben, dass sie jetzt US-B-Sticks in die andere Richtung einsetzen.
Hey, proven concept.
Das ist ja schon witzig, ja es funktioniert. Also ich habe ja, als ich ursprünglich das erste Mal darüber geblockt habe, habe ich ja gesagt, das sind wahrscheinlich die Russen. Ja, aber das war bevor ich die Statistik gesehen habe, dass 60 Prozent der Infektionen im Iran sind. Und Russland ist das Land, was gerade dem Iran hilft, diese Anlagen zu bauen.
Das ist nicht ganz richtig. Also ich hole mir ein bisschen aus dazu.
Aber also jedenfalls Russland glaube ich inzwischen nicht mehr.
Nee, also die Russen sind ja diejenigen, die den Iran benutzen als Hebel.
In Verhandlungen mit den Amis, ne?
In Verhandlungen mit den Amis. Der Iran möchte natürlich gerne möglichst eine Nuklearkapazität haben, damit die Amis ihn ernst nehmen. Weil wir haben ja in Nordkorea gesehen, dass wenn man mal eine Bombe hat, unter Pakistan und dann Indien, wenn man mal die Bombe hat, dann wird man plötzlich ernst genommen.
Na die sind ja auch umzingelt mit Leuten, die die Bombe haben und weniger stabile Regimes haben.
Also der Anspruch der Iraner, eine Bombe zu bauen, steht halt aus der Frage. Und eine der Möglichkeiten dazu ist, erstmal ein Atomkraftwerk aufzubauen, mit dem man mit eigenem angereichertem Uran wiederum Plutonium erzeugen kann als Beiprodukt der normalen Energiegewinnung. Um es dazu zu sagen, dass der Iran hat erhebliche Energieprobleme. Also es ist halt so, dass die die Aussage von denen, dass sie den Atomreaktor brauchen, um ihre Energieprobleme zu lösen, ist halt nicht aus der Luft gegriffen. Also das kann man anhand der Statistiken sehen. Die haben erhebliche Probleme mit ihrer industriellen Basis. Zum Beispiel haben sie zwar extrem viel Öl, aber keine ordentliche Raffinerie-Kapazität. Das also Benzin ist im Iran zeitweise rationiert. Zwar nicht, weil sie nicht genug Öl haben, sondern weil sie keine Raffinerie-Kapazitäten haben. Die Energieversorgung wurde davon, dass trotz Sanktionen und Embargos, da natürlich auch die modernen Zeiten angekehrt sind, immer starker Straub passiert, weil Leute immer größere Plasma-Fernseher haben. Man hat ja immer dieses Bild davon, dass Iran jetzt da die Lebenden in Lehmhütten und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, essen volle Tomaten, aber das ist nicht so. Der Iran ist halt ein hochgebildetes, hochkultiviertes Land mit einer großen industriellen Basis, die durch die Sanktionen natürlich beschädigt ist. Und die haben da natürlich ideologische Ansichten, die nicht mit den Nisiken kompatibel sind. Aber das heißt trotzdem nicht, dass es nicht, also was jetzt die Technologiebasis angeht und das Leben angeht, nicht eine moderne Nation ist.
Und wenn es da warm wird, dann möchten die auch gerne Klimaanlage haben.
Genau. So was heißt also diese ganze Ansage, dass jetzt die, die den Reaktor nur haben wollen, um sich da die Bomben zu bauen, stimmt halt so wiederum auch nicht. Und auch die Diskussionen offensichtlich innerhalb der iranischen Führung darüber, wie und in welchem Umfang jetzt dieses Autoprogramm betrieben wird und ob es nicht möglicherweise besser wäre, sich das abkaufen zu lassen dafür, dass man eben die Sanktionen losführt, ist halt eine, ja, bestimmte halt auch die politische Debatte so. Also es ist halt schon ja auch ein relativ politisch komplexes System, auch wenn es aus hiesiger Sicht immer so ein bisschen monolithisch aussieht. Aber die Geschichten zu den Wahlen und den Aufständen danach und so weiter und so fort zeigten halt auch, dass es halt ein System ist, was eine große innere Komplexität hat, auch wenn die für uns ein bisschen Alien erscheinen mag. So und die, insofern ist halt dieser Kontext zu den Russen, die helfen, den halt Boucher zu bauen, also den Reaktor da. Die haben Lieferverträge über Luftabwehrsysteme für den Iran und die Russen.
Aber nur den Reaktor übrigens, nicht den Rest von der Atominfrastruktur. Also ist vorhanden, ist von den Chinesen.
Genau und die Chinesen haben halt da solche Bedenken natürlich nicht. Also die lassen sich natürlich auch gerne von den Amis immer wieder was abhandeln, aber am Ende ist es halt so, dass alle benutzen den Iran als Hebel gegen die Verhandlung mit den Amis.
Na die Chinesen haben noch dazu das Problem, dass sie über ein Drittel von ihrem Öl aus dem Iran importieren. Also das heißt, wenn der Iran sagt, helft uns doch mal bitte, dann machen die das.
Das ist einfach völlig außer Frage. Die haben ja natürlich da auch wesentlich weniger ideologische Bedenken als alle anderen logischerweise. Und der Zustand des Iran eben in dieser permanenten Schwebe, dass halt von den Russen benutzt wird, um von den Amis raus zu handeln, dass wie in ihrem nahen Ausland, also sprich Ukraine und Georgien und so weiter und so fort, da ihnen dann niemand reinfuscht. Zum anderen, dass der Iran natürlich eine relativ große Hausmacht im Irak hat und sicherstellen will, dass da nie wieder ein Regime an die Macht kommt, was ihnen gefährlich wird, muss man halt auch verstehen. Also die Iraner haben halt keinen Bock darauf, dass im Irak da jemals wieder irgendwas an die Macht kommt, was wie der Krieg mit ihnen anfängt. Also dieses Trauma des Iran-Irak-Krieges ist da noch lange nicht vergessen.
Nicht zuletzt, weil die Amerikaner die Bio-Waffen und die chemischen Waffen geliefert haben, mit denen der Irak den Iran damals angegriffen hat.
Also diese Lage im Iran ist halt eine hochkomplexe und dementsprechend, gerade dadurch, dass die Russen dann einen relativ großen Hebel in der Hand halten, gerade was jetzt diesen Reaktor in Boucher angeht, halte ich es für relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass genau dieser Reaktor das Ziel gewesen sein soll. Zumal einige Teile von dem Code auch so aussehen, als wenn sie auf vielen gleichartigen Knoten von diesen Industrie-Steuerungen laufen, um halt viele gleichartige Prozesse zu manipulieren. Das passt eigentlich eher zu so einer Zentrifugen-Steuerung, wo du halt tausendfach dieselbe Konfiguration hast, die halt in einer vernetzten und halt ihre Input-Outputs und die Drehzahl kontrollieren muss.
Das kann auch einfach Sauber-Software-Engineering sein. Also man weiß es nicht. Aber ja, ich meine, die Theorie macht Sinn, dass man nicht den Atomreaktor angreift, sondern die...
Der zu dem Zeitpunkt übrigens überhaupt noch nicht in Betrieb war, in keiner Weise. Da war nicht mal spaltbares Material.
Das Datum, zu dem es heißt, dass sich der stuxnet automatisch aufhört, andere Leute zu infizieren, war Januar 2009 und da war Bushir noch eine weiter Ferne.
Also insofern, also die Vermutung, es gibt natürlich noch die weitere Vermutung, dass der Iran betreibt jetzt, zumindest Presseberichten zufolge, noch weitere Atomanlagen, die clandestin sind, also nicht bekannt sind, wo man möglicherweise weiß, wo die sind. Und von denen gerüchtet wird, dass es sich um so genannte Zwillinge von den offiziellen Anlagen handelt. Das heißt, dass dieselbe Konfiguration benutzt wird, dass dieselben Systeme benutzt werden, um natürlich die Kosten zu reduzieren, aber die dann eben benutzt werden, um halt höhere Anreichungsstufen zu erreichen. Also den nicht nur anzureichen wie Inertans auf ein Niveau, was für den Reaktor da ist, sondern auf höhere Anreichungsniveaus, die halt für Atomwaffen verwendbar sind.
Wikipedia hat übrigens eine längliche Liste mit Nuclear Facilities in Iran. Also das sind 17.
Die können wir dann mal verlinken. Insofern kann es halt auch durchaus sein, dass das Ziel eben nicht spezifisch Inertans war, sondern nur eine Anlage, so ähnlich wie Inertans, also eine Zentrifugenanlage. Oder möglicherweise eben auch ein vorherliegender Schritt der Aufbereitung. Also man muss dazu wissen, dass diese ganze Uran-Metallurgie, mit der man dann diese Brennstimme macht und sowas, halt super ekelige Prozesse, die sind halt alle nicht besonders schön und die auch im Rahmen ziemlich enger Parameter gehalten werden müssen. Also da muss man schon ziemlich aufpassen, da ist auch ziemlich viel Industriestauung unterwegs.
Also es gibt ja auch den Einwand, also jetzt zurück zu den S7-Sachen, es gab ja den Einwand, aber Skada, da würde man ja nur mit visualisieren und man kann höchstens ein paar Parameter setzen und nicht Code ändern. Selbst wenn das so wäre, also das haben wir versucht hier gerade darzustellen, die Prozesse sind so delikat, wenn man dann nur eine Nachkommastelle an irgendeinem der Sensoren ändert, ab wann der Alarm losgeht, dann reicht das eigentlich schon, um da massiven Schaden anzurichten.
Also eine der Theorien, die ein Kommentator bei mir im Blog hatte, war, dass der interpretierte den Code, der auf dem Speichelprogramm über den Steuerraum läuft, so, dass der subtil Drehzahlschwankungen induziert in den Zentrifugen, um den Verschleiß dieser Zentrifugen und die Verschleiß zu erhöhen und die Ausbote zu senken. Also halt einfach nur dafür sorgen, dass die Dinger schneller kaputt gehen und dass hinterher weniger angerichtet Material rauskommt, als wir eigentlich erwarten würden. Was sehr elegant wäre. Gut, ist nur eine Theorie, keine Ahnung, aber finde ich zumindest schon mal erwähnenswert.
Na, wir können ja mal kurz beleuchten, wen wir angreifen würden, wenn wir jetzt den Iran angreifen müssten. Also in der Kette der Schritte, die man braucht für die Anreicherung. Da bietet sich natürlich zuerst überhaupt erst mal die Anreicherung an mit den Zentrifugen, weil die so schön fragil sind. Aber warum würde man denn überhaupt Boucher angreifen wollen, wenn das nur ein Kraftwerk ist? Da gibt es nämlich auch noch ein Detail.
Na, dieses Detail ist, dass wenn man Plutonium haben möchte, um halt fortgeschritten Atomwaffen zu bauen, es gibt ja zwei Sorten Atomwaffen, einmal oranenbasierte Atomwaffen, die relativ primitive Designs sind, die auch nicht schwer zu bauen sind, aber für die man große Mengen Oranen braucht und die auch relativ groß und schwer sind und die in der Regel nicht so klein bekommen werden können, dass man sie auf Raketen tun kann. Wenn man portable Atomwaffen will, die also per Rakete gut zu transportieren sind, dann baut man Plutoniumwaffen noch. Das selbe gilt, wenn man zum Beispiel Wasserstoffbomben bauen will. Und die Plutoniumerzeugung funktioniert halt so, dass man Uran in ein Reaktor lädt, das dann eine Weile fährt, also halt damit Energie erzeugt und dann ein paar Parameter in der Neutronenflusssteuerung so wählt, dass hinterher in den Brennstäben eine gewisse Menge Plutonium entsteht. Also einfach durch die isotopen Umwandlung im Prozess der Kernspaltung werden bestimmte Mengen Plutonium erzeugt. Und dieses Plutonium muss man dann da rausholen aus diesem Brennstäben. Was auch echt eklig ist. Also dann wird es halt richtig eklig. So also Plutoniumisolierung aus Brennstäben funktioniert halt so, dass man diese Brennstäbe aufsägt. Also wohlgemerkt Brennstäbe, die halt schon eine Weile in so einem Atomkraftwerk vor sich hingestrahlt haben.
Na Plutonium ist auch ein echt unsympathischer Stoff.
Komme ich gleich zu. Die voll sind mit echt radioaktiven giftigen Stoffen. Also man sägt die halt in so Kammern auf, die halt komplett isoliert sind. Dann holt man da ja dieses Isotopengemisch raus, was aus dem Uran geworden ist und fängt an, das auseinander zu popeln. Und zwar chemisch. Sondern die man halt die chemischen Stoffeigenschaften benutzt, um halt sie voneinander zu isolieren. Also man löst das ganze Zeug in Säuren auf. Dann hat man also giftige, radioaktive Säuremumpe. Und aus dieser giftigen, radioaktiven Säuremumpe erzeugt man damit über verschiedene Reaktionsschritte, wo man halt die einzelnen Elemente wiederum an andere Elemente bindet. Und dann wiederum daraus die reinen Elemente isoliert. Und dann Plutonium und Thorium und was man sonst noch so haben will an Stoffen, die für so eine Waffenentwicklung sinnvoll sind. Plutonium an sich ist so eines der unsympathischsten Elemente auf diesem planeten überhaupt. Also es ist halt ein Metall, aber es hat halt vier verschiedene Elementarphasen und deren Übergänge sind so ein bisschen nonlinear. Also die hängen so mit Drückentemperaturen und der Richtung des Temperaturwechsels zusammen. Also die Plutoniummetallurgie ist halt schon, ist ein eigenes Fach so. Also da kann man halt, also die Metallurgie der Transurane, da gibt es halt ganze Institute im Westen und auch in Russland, die sich mit sowas beschäftigen, weil es halt nichts mit normaler Metallurgie mehr zu tun hat. So wie denn man will ja am Ende dieses Metall irgendwie schmelzen. Also es ist dann halt zum Beispiel so Halbkugeln oder Kartoffel-förmigen Objekten, Formen, aus denen man dann die Bomben macht. Und da wird es dann halt schon richtig widerlich so. Da möchte man halt also gut isolierte Facilities haben mit Leuten, die wissen, was man tut und so.
Also da geht auch niemand von aus, der ist der Iran, dieses Wissen oder Know-how hat. Aber wenn sie da jetzt im Boucher die Brennstoffe verwerten, dann bleibt halt am Ende Plutonium übrig. Und das reicht ja, wenn sie darauf sitzen, bis sie das Know-how haben müssen.
Deswegen gibt es ja diesen Deal, dass der Iran halt seinen Uran an die Russen gibt, die Russen ihnen halt daraus Brennstäbe bauen, die Brennstäbe nach Boucher gehen, sie die Brennstäbe da fahren und dann die Brennstäbe wieder zu den Russen zurückgehen. Also das war jetzt so einer der vorgeschlagenen Deals, um sicherzustellen, dass die Iraner halt kein Plutonium in die Hand bekommen und die IAEA passt halt auf auf den Kram. Also wir erinnern uns zum Beispiel an die Nordkorea-Geschichte, wo jedes Mal, wenn Kim irgendwie wieder einen neuen Reis brauchte oder seine Kohle alle war, hat er halt angefangen...
Kraftwerk rot zu fahren.
Nee, nee, hat er die Siegel an den Brennstäben abgemacht und halt angefangen hat, die Brennstäbe zu extrahieren und dann erst mal anzufangen. Wir fangen jetzt mal mit der Plutonium-Geschichte an. Aber was wir jetzt sehen an Nordkorea ist, dass auch ein Land unter Embargo, was sehr viel ärmer ist als Iran, also Nordkorea ist ja ziemlich am Eimer so, selbst die sind durchaus in der Lage, so eine Atomtechnologie-Kette sich zusammenzuschnauern und aufzubauen. Im Prinzip geht das schon, aber das ist natürlich mit großem Aufwand verbunden. Was auch einer der Gründe ist, warum zum Beispiel im Iran halt die stimmen sich mehr, die halt sagen, also ist es denn überhaupt wert, jetzt diesen Stress zu fahren da mit allen de facto, nur um da einen Atomkraftwerk zu bauen, finden wir dann nicht möglicherweise eine andere Lösung, die halt weniger anstrengend ist.
Lieber eine Graffinerie bauen. Aber die wäre halt auch Skala betrieben.
Aber es ist halt natürlich eine Frage des nationalen Stolzes und all dieser irrationalen Dinge, die man da berücksichtigen muss, wo man halt natürlich wenig gegen tun kann. Naja, was wir jetzt noch unerwähnt gelassen haben, sind die Sachen mit den Vulnerability Markts, also wie die verkauft werden. Da solltest du vielleicht noch ein bisschen was zu erzählen, wie die eigentlich entstanden sind. Also warum halt solche Siode-Experts und auch solche Verwundbarkeiten zur Handelsware geworden sind.
Ja, also das ging alles damit los, die guten alten Zeiten bei Windows 95 und so. Da gab es eine Schwemme an Lücken. Da gab es genug Lücken für alle. Und da war die einzelne Lücke nicht besonders wertvoll, weil es halt so viele davon gab. Und wer eine gefunden hat, hat sie halt veröffentlicht oder hat sie von mir aus benutzt. Aber das war damals noch kein Geschäft. Also das heißt, wenn man so eine Lücke benutzt hat, hat man das für Spaß gemacht. Und nicht, um damit Geld zu verdienen. Inzwischen ist das so, dass die Hersteller angefangen haben, insbesondere Microsoft eben, weil sie so in der Schusslinie waren. Die haben einfach angefangen damit, wenn sie schon die Lücken nicht geschlossen haben, also haben sie zwar auch versucht, aber das ist halt immer ein Prozess und keine Sache, die man irgendwann erreicht hat, haben sie halt angefangen Mitigations einzubauen. Das heißt, sie machen es einfach schwieriger, die Sachen auszunutzen. Selbst wenn die Lücken noch da sind, versuchen sie halt, das Ausnutzen so weit zu erschweren, dass es keine stabilen Exploits mehr gibt. Also es ist zwar noch nicht erreicht, aber es wird halt zunehmend schwieriger. Und ein stabiler Exploit ist einer, den ich einmal losschieße und der funktioniert immer. Und das wird zusehends schwieriger. Also es gibt da zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, normalerweise würde man halt, was man machen kann, dass man irgendein Stück Code ausführen kann auf dem Rechner, wenn man weiß, wo es ist. Und das war einer der ersten Angriffspunkte und einer der wichtigsten auch, dass man eben geguckt hat, dass man nicht vorhersagen kann, wo der Code jetzt genau ist. Es gibt zwar immer Wege und Mittel, trotzdem noch einen stabilen Exploit hinzukriegen, aber das ist inzwischen schwierig genug, dass es halt nur noch wenige Leute echt beherrschen. Und dadurch ist das ein Markt geworden. Es ist inzwischen so, dass wenn man so eine Lücke hat, dann gibt es eben verschiedene Klassen von Lücken. Also die teuersten Lücken sind die, mit denen ich aus der Ferne einen Rechner infizieren kann, ohne dass der quasi mich anspricht. Also wenn ich einfach ein Paket hinschicken kann, so was wie Ping of Death wäre in uns vielleicht, wenn ich einfach ein Paket hinschicke oder ich mache einfach eine Verbindung auf zu dem Rechner und schicke ihm was und dann kann ich ihn fernsteuern. Das sind die teuersten Lücken, die gibt es so gut wie gar nicht mehr. Das ist echt selten geworden. Wenn man sowas kaufen will auf dem freien Markt, zahlt man da schon mal eine halbe Million für. Das sind echt Lücken, die sind so selten, die gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr.
In der Klasse ist eigentlich auch dieser LNK-Exploit, diese USB-Data.
Genau, dieser LNK-Exploit, als der zuerst aufgefallen ist, war das nur ein USB-Exploit, aber der funktioniert auch über Webdev oder SMB. Das ist aus dieser Kategorie. Allein daraus, dass diese Lücke in stuxnet benutzt wird, kann man schon sagen, dass die Entwicklung von stuxnet mindestens eine Million gekostet haben muss.
Wahrscheinlich eher mehr.
Eher mehr, aber wir sind bei einer Mindesteinschätzung von siebenstellig. Dann gibt es die nächste Kategorie an Problemen, sind Sachen, mit denen man auf der Kiste selber sich mehr Zugriff beschaffen kann. Also wenn ich jetzt einen Rechner-Account habe und das ist nicht mein Rechner, dann habe ich normalerweise nicht den Administratorzugang und kann zum Beispiel nicht einfach Software installieren oder löschen. Und um den Zugriff auf der Kiste selber zu erweitern, das ist die nächste Kategorie an Lücken, da gibt es schon deutlich mehr von. Aber die kosten immer noch Geld, aber das ist eher so, weiß ich nicht, 50.000.
Also mehr so 10.000, nicht 100.000 von dort.
Genau, also das ist zwar immer noch teuer, aber die mit Abstand teuerste Kategorie sind eben die aus der Ferne. Und da sind wir inzwischen so weiter, die so Lücken so selten sind, dass wir sagen, es gilt auch schon als solche Lücke, wenn ich über den Browser sowas machen kann. Also wenn ich quasi als Vorbedingung habe, dass die Kiste, die ich infizieren will, mit ihrem Browser zu mir eine Verbindung aufbaut oder mit irgendeiner anderen Software. Auch das gilt inzwischen schon in der höchsten Kategorie als Remote-Exploit, weil es einfach die anderen quasi nicht mehr gibt. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt hier eine Mailware sehen, die vier Lücken hat, von denen zwei in der Top-Kategorie und zwei, in der darunter sind, dann kostet allein die Anschaffung von diesen Exploits schon mal eine Million. Dieser Markt funktioniert so, dass manche Leute sich damit richtig den Lebensunterhalt finanzieren, dass sie Lücken suchen. Da gibt es also legitime Firmen, denen man das verkaufen kann und weniger legitime Firmen, denen man das verkaufen kann.
Genau, wer kauft denn sowas?
Genau, wer kauft denn sowas? Also es gibt halt ein paar Firmen, die quasi sagen, wenn wir euch die Lücke abkaufen, dann bauen wir das in unsere Detection-Software ein und die erkennt dann, wenn jemand über diese Lücke angegriffen wird. Das kann man jetzt glauben oder nicht. Ich persönlich halte diese ganzen Detection-Software alle für. Genau, Snake Oil, das ist alles Schlankenmüll. Aber das ist also eine Art von legitimer Firma, die sowas kauft und es gibt so eine Art Markt darüber, dass diese Firmen inzwischen alle nicht mehr selbstständig sind, sondern sagen wir von Leuten wie HP oder so gekauft worden sind, von großen Konzernen, IBM, dass die eben mit der Lücke dann zum Hersteller gehen und der Hersteller fixt das dann und in dem Patch steht drin, vielen Dank an Firmenname.
Ich weiß, die kaufen sich so ein bisschen Ruhm.
Die kaufen sich Ruhm damit, genau. Und die sagen, ja, wir haben das zuerst gefunden und die können dann darauf quasi verweisen in ihrer Werbung.
Also sicher als Kompetenz.
Genau, aber die zahlen eben auch nicht so viel, wenn es da für nur Ruhm gibt.
Also ein paar Zehntausend maximal, ja.
Genau. Nun ist es so, dass manche Leute, die professionelle Lücken suchen, möchten nicht so erwähnt werden eigentlich. Sie möchten lieber Geld dafür haben und deswegen gibt es zwei Modelle. Es gibt das eine Modell, dass quasi die Firma dann deinen Namen für sich behält und dir zwar Geld gibt, aber sie steht nur drin. Und es gibt aber auch das Modell, dass dein Name auch noch erwähnt wird. Aber viele Leute, die professionelle Lücken suchen, wollen auch gar nicht, dass ihr Name da steht, weil das bringt dich ja auch in die Schusslinie. Wenn bekannt ist, dass du da Kompetenzen hast, dann entführt dich möglicherweise irgendwann jemand und dann musst du da im Keller sitzen und kodieren. Das will bei dir alles nicht. So und dann gibt es natürlich noch andere Möglichkeiten. Es gibt also einen regelrechten Schwarzmarkt, wie man solche Lücken verscheuern kann. Das sind dann eben Geheimdienste, von denen man auch nicht unbedingt weiß, ob das inländische oder ausländische Geheimdienste sind.
Die benutzen dann Mittelsmänner, oder wie?
Die benutzen Mittelsmänner, genau. Das Problem ist eben, wenn man sich einmal auf so etwas einlässt, das ist halt nicht abschätzbar, ob man sich da in Teufelsküche begibt oder nicht. Deswegen, die Leute, die ich kenne, machen sowas alles nicht. Sagen sie zumindest.
Ach, da sind sie gerade mal die Politik abzahlen müssen.
Ja, naja, also die geheimnischen zahlen theoretisch mehr. Aber das kann halt sein, dass die quasi dir dann sowas wie eine Ausreiseerlaubnis nicht mehr geben.
Ach so.
Also das ist halt doof. Nehmen wir mal an, du fängst jetzt an als Amerikaner mit der CIA zu verhandeln. Das ist genauso, wie wenn du in irgendwelchen geheimen Flugzeugbausachen mitarbeitest. Dann kannst du auch nicht mehr das Land verlassen. Und da gibt es halt unabsehbare Risiken.
Deswegen gehen die Leute lieber mittels Männer und wissen lieber, wie sie verkauft haben.
Es gibt auch mittels Männer, die Leuten ihre Lücken abkaufen und die verkaufen es dann an Geheimdienst.
Verstehe, damit du dann halt problemlos bist.
Aber eigentlich ist das alles eher unerfreulich, weil ob das jetzt Geheimdienst oder organisierte Kriminalität ist, das ist ja beides, eigentlich keine Leute, mit denen man zusammenarbeiten will.
Aber was ist denn aus Full Disclosure geworden? Früher waren wir doch alle mal Idealisten.
Früher waren wir alle.
Als es noch genug Lücken für alle da war.
Das gibt es auch noch für die Lücken. Aber es gibt es seltener für Exploits. Es gibt eine Ausnahme, es gibt die Metasploit-Leute, die bemühen sich eben, wenn eine Lücke bekannt wird, dann auch sofort einen Exploit dafür zu basteln. Aber die ist halt selten so, dass die wirklich selber die Lücken suchen. Das machen die zwar auch, aber die haben sich eigentlich darauf spezialisiert, sobald irgendwas bekannt wird. Genau, aber die haben eigentlich auch einen Day-Job. Die brauchen also das Geld nicht mehr unbedingt.
Der Metasploit ist doch gekauft worden. Die sind doch irgendwie jetzt Teil von irgendeiner anderen Security-Bude, aber machen es weiter bei der Mietung.
Ja, also ich würde jedenfalls sagen, das sind keine hungernen Studenten. Das heißt, die haben es nicht mit sich da. Die müssen nicht, das ist korrekt. Aber so der Markt für, ich poste jetzt einen Exploit, der ist eigentlich weg.
Und glaubst du denn, dass die Exploits in stuxnet, ob die gekauft wurden oder dass die selber gefunden wurden?
Das sieht sehr so aus, dass die gekauft wurden. Das sieht man daran, dass die Exploits eine andere Programmiertechnik benutzen und dass die auch mit verschiedenen Versionen des Compilers gebaut worden sind. Also es sieht so aus, als wenn die auch tatsächlich von verschiedenen Leuten programmiert worden sind. Und das deutet daraufhin entweder, also es gibt zwei Theorien, entweder sie haben sie gekauft, das ist so die mir sympathische Theorie, weil das heißt eben, dass die Leute, die stuxnet programmiert haben, nicht irgendwie Supermänner sind. Oder es gibt eben die Theorie, dass da die Smartesten der Smarten in irgendeinem fiesen Keller sitzen.
Der Besten, Sir.
Genau, dass genau die Leute in irgendeinem Keller sitzen und uns alle ownen können, das will ich ja nicht hoffen. Das ist natürlich nicht auszuschließen, aber.
Okay, also wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, dass sie es zusammen gekauft haben, bis auf ein oder zwei Ausnahmen oder so.
Es sieht sehr so aus, als wenn sie das zusammen gekauft haben. Und da würde ich mal von ausgehen.
Na gut, also gerade diese LNK-Exploit, ich meine, das wäre halt genau das zum Beispiel gewesen, als wir damals diese Wahlstiftgeschichte gemacht haben.
Der ist vor allem deswegen brutal, weil es eben so ein Design-Exploit ist. Also das ist nicht eine Sache, wo man irgendwelche Offsets braucht, sondern das funktioniert einfach.
Also wer sich erinnert, wir hatten ja damals diese Geschichte mit dem Wahlstift und da gab es unter anderem auch die Geschichte, dass eines der Probleme bei dem Wahlstiftdesign war, dass man über einen Wahlstift, in den halt ein manipulierter OSB-Stick eingebaut wird, den Rechner, auf dem die Ausfindung stattfinden konnte, und da gingen unter anderem der Streit dann darum, ob denn sowas überhaupt möglich ist, also ob denn nicht der Rechner so gut geschützt werden könnte, dass genau das nicht geht, und wie sich jetzt bei diesem LNK-Exploit halt deutlich zeigt, da gibt es halt immer wieder Sachen, die kann man einfach nicht wissen, die kann auch Microsoft nicht wissen, zum Beispiel Microsoft, glaube ich, OSB als Angriffszenario noch nicht so richtig auf ihrem Radar hatte für lange Zeit.
Ja, das hat sich geändert als dein wireless OSB-Gap. Ja, bei der Wahlschriftsache war unser Standpunkt, ja, sowas gibt es, aber wir zeigen es euch nicht. Und wir hatten auch kein Greifbar, können wir mal ganz ehrlich sagen, aber wir haben auch keine Lust gehabt, danach zu suchen. Denn wenn man da in der Bringschuld ist, hat man eigentlich immer verloren. Denn wenn wir jetzt so einen Exploit finden und den zeigen, dann gehen die damit zu Microsoft und Microsoft fixt es. Und dann sind wir auf Square One und haben gerade einen Verdienst von einer halben Million ausgeschlagen, wenn wir das auf dem Schwarzmarkt hätten versteuert können. Also ich weiß, wir natürlich nicht tun, gleich mal dem endieren an der Stelle. Aber da können wir keinen Gewinn mitmachen, wenn wir jetzt irgendwelche Exploits rausrücken, um den Wahlstift argumentativ vor Gericht zu lassen.
Da ging es halt auch tatsächlich ums Prinzip und wie sich jetzt gezeigt hat, war unsere Argumentation mit dem Prinzip vollständig richtig, dass nämlich solche Exploits unterwegs sind und dass es sie gibt und dass im Zweifel einen Schutz dagegen, also gegen diesen LNK-Exploit, hätte es de facto kein Schutz gegeben, egal was da für ein Betriebssystem drauf und wie gut abgesichert ist.
Naja, also wenn es Linux gewesen wäre.
Du bist ja so sicher, dass der Linux...
Linux hat Punkt-Desktop-Dateien, die sind auch total unsicher. Ja, also man kann natürlich alles irgendwie angreifen, aber...
Ja genau, also das ist halt eben genau eigentlich der Punkt. Also man kann eben alles irgendwie angreifen. Das zeigt ja schon, also die Mühe, die da reingesteckt wurde in diesen stuxnet, haben halt ja genau diesen Punkt rein. Man kann eigentlich alles irgendwie angreifen, wenn der Aufwand, den man treibt, groß genug ist. Und genau den Aufwand haben sie da offensichtlich getrieben, um eben mal irgendwie eine Anlage anzugreifen, die sonst off limits ist, offensichtlich.
Es zeigt auch ein schönes Dilemma auf, denn es gibt ja normalerweise so die Argumentation, ja wir patchen immer alles. Das hat aber den Nachteil, dass man am internet hängt. Ja und dann kann man sagen, okay aus Sicherheitsgründen hängen wir uns nicht ans internet und dann müssen wir auch nicht patchen. Und dann sieht man eben, das stimmt nicht. Also stuxnet hat nicht nur die neuen Vulnerabilities benutzt, sondern eben auch die alte, die der Configure Wurm auch schon benutzt hat. Und wenn man jetzt so was ja durchaus anzunehmen ist, dass so eine Anlage, die nicht am internet hängt, nicht gepatcht ist, na klar und dann kommt man auch mit so einer alten Vulnerability innerhalb der Anlage überall hin. Also man hat da verloren, wie man es macht. Wenn man immer schön patcht, hat man verloren. Und wenn man nicht ins internet hängt, hat man auch verloren. Und das ist eigentlich die große Lektion an der Stelle.
Also die Lektion ist halt, also Luftspalt hilft halt auch nicht. Bisher war eben die Ansage, also Luftspalt zwischen den Computern und dem Netz zu halten, ist halt der einzige sichere Weg, sicher zu sein, dass man sich nichts einfängt. Aber irgendwie muss man ja die Software-Updates darauf kriegen.
Der große Schenkelklopfer war ja, dass also zumindest eine Spekulation in der Presse war, warum die da überhaupt mit dem USB-Stick hingelaufen sind, war, um den Lizenzschlüssel aufzuspielen. Und das finde ich ja persönlich sehr sympathisch, weil das nämlich heißt, wenn wir diesen ganzen Kopierschutz-Scheiß endlich mal sein lassen würden, der einfach unglaublich Geld kostet, volkswirtschaftlich und betriebswirtschaftlich und gar nichts bringt, weil einfach trotzdem alles geklaut und kopiert werden kann, dann hätten wir auch dieses Problem nicht gehabt. Aber so ist es halt.
Ja, noch eine andere Sache, die wir vorhin schon erwähnt hatten, war diese Sache mit diesen Zertifikaten. Da ging es ja darum, um sich in den Körner zu installieren von dem angegriffenen Betriebssystem, der Wurms Zertifikate mitbringt, also digitale Unterschriften. Und da sollten wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen darauf eingehen, was die Bedeutung von diesen Dingern ist und wie so interessant es ist, dass die mit geklauten thalwanesischen Zertifikaten da unterwegs waren.
Ja, das war eine der frühen Versuche, gegen Malware vorzugehen. Also die Idee, dass man so einen Anti-Viren-Scanner hat, der eben deine Dateien alle anguckt und sagt, oh den kenn ich, das ist ein Virus. Auf Dauer kann das nicht skalieren, weil einfach die Viren schneller nachkommen. Man kann per Definition nur die finden, die bekannt sind oder die bekannte Methoden anwenden. Und da sind eben nicht alle. Und dann war eine der offensichtlichen Ideen, ist natürlich, man hat eine Whitelist. Also man weiß einfach, diese Datei ist koscher. Und der erste Ansatz dafür war, dass einfach Microsoft ihre Dateien signiert. Und dann weiß man, okay, das ist eine ordentliche Microsoft-Datei.
Und die dann das Betriebssystem prüft, ob die Signatur in Ordnung ist, bevor der Code ausgeführt wird. Das wäre die Idee gewesen. Die Idee dabei, dass man halt etwas sagt, okay, auf diesem System kommt nur Code zur Ausführung, der eine Signatur hat, also mit einer digitalen Unterschrift signiert ist. Und nur der Code bekommt dann eben Zutritt zum Kernel Space. Also kann sich halt als Treiber so tief ins Betriebssystem installieren, dass er eigentlich fast alles tun kann.
Oh, es geht nicht nur um Kernel Space. Also es geht auch darum, wenn du eine Datei aus dem internet runterlädst und du klickst dann drauf unter Windows, dann kommt so ein Fenster hoch. Achtung, diese Datei ist aus dem internet. Sie ist signiert von Adobe. Willst du den trauen? Ja, und klar, wenn die von Microsoft signiert sind, also eine der Hürden, die es dann gab, ist, naja, um einen Kernel-Treiber laden zu dürfen, muss man signiert sein. Das sollte halt verhindern, dass irgendwelche Virenschreiber einfach einen Kernel-Treiber schreiben und laden. Aber die Virenschreiber können sich natürlich auch selber ein Zertifikat besorgen. Deswegen war quasi die Verteidigungslinie an der Stelle, dass man eben dann das komplette Zertifikat für ungültig erklären kann, sobald einer damit ein Stück Mailware signiert hat. Und was jetzt an stuxnet neu war, ist, dass diese Zertifikate eben von tatsächlich existierenden realen Herstellern von Hardware waren. Nämlich einer von J-Micron, die bauen so Data-Adapter und sowas. Und das andere war Realtek, die bauen Soundkarten und alles mögliche. Der Netzwerk, alles. Also das sind große, taiwanesische Anbieter, die lustigerweise an einer Stelle ein Office nah beieinander haben in einem Industriepark in China. Deswegen gibt es also eine der Theorien, dass die halt einfach da eingebrochen sind.
Also physisch eingebrochen sind. Ja.
Also man sieht, diese Signaturen sind natürlich sowieso nur ein Pflaster.
Aber die gibt es doch eigentlich erst seit Vista oder sowas, wenn du richtig ausgewertet bist.
Signaturen gibt es schon früher, aber die Einschränkung, dass du einen Colonel 3x0 laden darfst, wenn er signiert ist, die ist ab Vista. Und auch nur auf 64-Bit, auf 32-Bit konnte man immer noch irgendwie drumrum fummeln.
Und bei Windows 7?
Aber bei 64-Bit ist das auch Zwang. Aber man kann sich ja überlegen, dass das kein echter Schutz ist. Das ist auch von vornherein klar gewesen. Denn ich kann natürlich auch, wenn irgendwo eine Lücke gefunden wird in so einem Colonel-Treiber und ich release eine neue Version, dann ist die zwar auch wieder unterschrieben, aber die alte ist auch unterschrieben. Das heißt, wenn ich nur prüfe, es signiert, dann kann ich damit auch die alte...
Die kaputte signieren, ja.
Genau, die kaputte kann ich wieder installieren und quasi mir die Hintertür einfangen. Das heißt, die Signatur, das war schon von vornherein klar, das ist eher so eine PR-Maßnahme.
Interessant ist ja, dass, weswegen ich auf diese Vista und Sieben-Sach hinaus wollte, offensichtlich wusste der Angreifer ja extrem genau, was jetzt in diesem Industrieanlagen-Kontrollteil der Software funktioniert.
Da ist ein Check drin, der läuft nur unter XP und 2003. Das fand ich auch auffallend.
Aber trotzdem haben sie sich die Mühe gemacht, die Signatur und so anzustellen, dass ihr Verbreitungscode auf allen Windows-Versionen wirklich funktioniert, also eben die Signaturen auch da zu haben.
Das ist üblich bei Mailware inzwischen. Das ist so eine Art Baukastenprinzip. Also du hast die kommerzielle Mailware, die es im Moment gibt. Da kauft man so eine Art Installer und da klickt man an. Ich möchte gern diese Lücke ausnutzen, diese Lücke ausnutzen, diese Lücke ausnutzen. Ich möchte gern dieses Modul haben zum Fernsteuern. Ich möchte gern folgendes reinklicken und dann möchte ich gern diesen Debugging-Schutz haben. Und dann bastelt der daraus ein Binary. Und die einzelnen Module kommen von verschiedenen Leuten. Das Modul für die Fernsteuerung kommt von jemanden, der sie mit Fernsteuern auskennt. Das Modul für die Infektion kommt von jemanden, der sie mit Infektionen auskennt und der infiziert alles. Das Modul, was dann tatsächlich angreift, der muss nur XP und 2003 angreifen können. Und daher läuft der dann auf weniger System. Aber die Lücken, die wir ausnutzen, die werden tatsächlich auf allen Systemen funktioniert.
Diese Signaturgeschichte wirft natürlich noch mal ein interessantes Licht auf dieses generelle Problem mit dieser Public-Key-Infrastruktur, die dahinter steht.
Das ist im Grunde alles Scheiße. Die können wir vielleicht an der Stelle mal ansagen.
Das Problem ist, was Fefe gerade schon sagte, diese Geschichte, dass der, wenn so eine Signatur mal verloren gegangen ist, dann muss die ja irgendwie wieder rufen werden. Also dann müssen alle, bei denen diese Signatur installiert ist, irgendwie mitgeteilt werden, dass diese Signatur jetzt leider gerade verloren gegangen ist, wenn man zum Bereitmiss mitbekommen hat, was sie offensichtlich nicht mitbekommen haben. Und dass man dann die halt revoken sollte. Das ist halt eine Teil des Problems. Der andere Teil des Problems ist halt natürlich, von wem werden diese Signaturen eigentlich ausgestellt? Und wer ist denn da sozusagen die vertrauenswürdige Partei, der man da gerade vertrauen soll?
Also das erste Problem ist, dass die Revocation-Checking, also die Prüfung, ist die Signatur gültig, übers internet funktioniert. Und wenn ich jetzt ein Kraftwerk hab, was kein internet hat, dann klappt das halt nicht. Das war das erste Problem. Das zweite Problem ist, wie prüf ich denn, ob eine Signatur gültig ist oder nicht? Das läuft normalerweise so, dass man X509 benutzt. Das ist so der Standard, den man da hat für Signaturen im internet. Das geht auf den ISO-Standard zurück. Und das funktioniert so, dass man einen ursprünglichen Root-Zertifikat herausgebar hat. Das ist jemand wie, sagen wir, VeriSign oder Microsoft macht sowas auch. Und der hat dann ein Zertifikat, das irgendwie 30 Jahre gültig. Da steht dann sowas wie, läuft aus 2063. Also irgendwann weit genug in der Ferne, dass wir das gerade noch abbilden können mit unserem Zeitformular, Darstellung, Computer. Und mit dem Zertifikat unterschreibt man dann ein anderes Zertifikat. Also es gibt so die Operation, die man hat an der Stelle. Kryptographisch ist das, dass ich was unterschreibe. Also ich signiere das. Und das bedeutet quasi, dass jemand, der das Stück Daten hat und meine Signatur sehen kann, dass diese Signaturen nur von mir hätte kommen können. Weil da ein Stück Daten beteiligt ist, die ich nie rausgerückt habe. Man unterteilt quasi diese Kryptosachen in einmal einen privaten und öffentlichen Schlüssel. Und den öffentlichen, den gebe ich halt allen. Und mit dem öffentlichen Schlüssel und meiner Signatur kann man prüfen, dass die Signature nur von meinem privaten Schlüssel hätte kommen können. So funktioniert das. So, das heißt jetzt, wenn VeriSign eine Root-CA hat, so nennt sich das, CA ist Certification Authority. Also wenn die so ein Root-Zertifikat haben, dann müssen die das verbreiten, damit alle Leute, die die Zertifikate, also die Signaturen prüfen wollen, die müssen dann eine Kopie von dem von dem Root-Zertifikat haben, damit sie das prüfen können. Und das heißt, dass Windows oder auch sowas wie Firefox, also jeder, der Zertifikate prüfen will, der muss eine Liste von Root-Zertifikaten haben, den er traut. Und diese Liste ist erschütternd lang, wenn man sich das mal ansieht bei Windows oder Firefox.
Das kann man in seinem Browser mal aufklappen.
Das solltet ihr alle mal tun, das ist nämlich augenöffnend.
Und das Security, die Zertifikate, wen ihr da alle vertraut, da sind auch irgendwie etliche chinesische Regierungsbehörden dabei.
Na, die Telekom ist dabei. Das ist ja eine deutsche Regierungsstelle, wenn wir das mal mit den Chinesen vergleichen.
So ungefähr alle, die irgendwie groß sind, irgendwie Institutionen sind, sind da drinnen. Aber auch jede Menge lustige kleine Buden, die es teilweise auch nicht mal mehr gibt. Also gerade bei Firefox fehlt es mir auch noch nicht wieder oft. Da sind halt jede Menge Firmen drinnen, die, ich weiß nicht, die gibt es, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr oder so. Und da ist völlig unklar, in wessen Händen aus der Insolvenzmasse dann irgendwie das Zertifikat geladen ist, mit dem man da irgendwie Sachen unterschreiben kann.
Also der Punkt ist jedenfalls, wenn jetzt ein Stück Code kommt und bei deinem Windows in den Kernel geladen werden will, dann prüft Windows die Signatur und guckt, ob das von einem vertrauenswürdigen Signator unterschrieben wurde. Und zwar nicht direkt, sondern es gibt da eben so eine Kaskade. Aber am Ende kommt es raus bei Leuten wie VeriSign.
Ja, und die, also bedeutsam ist es halt auch, weil genau derselbe Mechanismus wird halt verwendet für Webseiten, die per SSL, also wenn dann oben HTTPS in der Browserzeile steht, genau derselbe Mechanismus wird da verwendet. Und genau da werden auch genau dieselben Zertifikatmechanismen verwendet, wie diese Publikierinfrastruktur. Und da gibt es halt auch allerhande Methoden, um die anzugreifen. So, also unter anderem, sich einfach das Zertifikat für die Webseite, die man gerade besuchen will, unterschreiben zu lassen von einem der großen, oder wenn man selber so ein Zertifikat in der Hand hat, das dynamisch zu machen. Was dann passiert ist, dann sitzt der Angreifer in der Mitte zwischen dir und deiner Bank zum Beispiel, oder dir und deinem Oppositionsblock, was du gerade irgendwie pflegen möchtest. Und was er dann tut, ist, er nimmt halt die Signatur von der Webseite und fälscht die. Und zwar so, dass dein Browser dir nicht anzeigt, dass es sich gerade verändert hat. Es gibt jetzt da relativ wenig Methoden. Es gibt halt einen Firefox-Plugin, was in der Lage ist, zu erkennen. Das werden wir auch noch verlinken. Ja, also diese Zertifikate, diese ganze Zertifikatsgeschichte ist halt ein relativ unschönes Thema, was man sicherlich noch mal weiter beschäftigen wird. Auch bei Webseiten gibt es da genauso wenig Sicherheit am Ende, wenn man all diesen ganzen Leuten vertraut und eben nicht tracken kann, welches Zertifikat von wem gesigned ist und wer Zugriff auf diese Zertifikate hat. Also da ist halt also ziemliche Augenwischerei statt Sicherheit.
Das kann man schon kaufen als Produkt fertig für Law Enforcement Agencies. So ein Teil, was eben dann eine eigene CA hat, die in Browsern drin steht. Und wenn ich jetzt hingehe und mich zu was weiß ich, der Postbank oder was connecten will per SSL, dann erkennt dieses Gerät das und baut schnell ein Zertifikat, was mit ihrem Kram unterschrieben ist, aber behauptet Postbank zu sein. Und dann kann man Browser den Unterschied eben nicht kennen. Das heißt, die Technologie, um das zu umgehen, gibt es schon. Und das ist derselbe Kram, der benutzt wird, um Malware aus einem Körner fernzuhalten. Also der Stand der Technik ist nicht gut.
Wobei es im Wesentlichen ja nicht der Stand der Technik ist, sondern der Stand des vertrauensnetzes, was dahintersteht. Die Frage ist, wem kann man da gerade noch vertrauen?
Das ist halt gut klar.
Es sind halt zu viele Leute, denen da per default vertraut wird.
Ja. Auch wenn du die alle wegklickst. Eine der größten, mit den meisten Signaturen an der Stelle, ist, glaube ich, GoDaddy, die so 5 Dollar Domains verscheuern.
Mit Signatur?
Na, mit Signatur wahrscheinlich 15 oder keine Ahnung. Aber also jedenfalls billigst. Und da kann man sich vorstellen, viel geprüft wird da nicht. Die Frage ist natürlich, wie kommt jetzt der Mailware-Hersteller an die gefälschten Signaturen? Einbruch ist eine Sache, aber erwähnenswert ist, dass es auch schon andere Mailware gab, botnetze, die auf den kompromittierten Rechnern geguckt haben, ob sie da nicht Zertifikate finden.
Und die Signaturen geklaut haben.
Und die Signaturen geklaut haben, genau. Das ist schon seit längerem bekannt, dass das quasi irgendwann kommt, dass Mailware signiert ist. Und jetzt werden wir uns halt was Neues überlegen müssen. Ein neues Pflaster, mit dem wir wieder ein halbes Jahr oben bin können.
Ach so, ein bisschen Snake Oil.
Na klar, genau.
Ein Snake Oil-Pflaster.
Hilf gegen alles.
So, damit wären wir, glaube ich, mal wieder durch. Diesmal hat es eine etwas längere Sendung geworden. Nochmal der Hinweis, es ist bald Kongress. Wir suchen noch nach interessanten Vorträgen, insbesondere von Energieversorgern über Industrial-Control-Systeme, aber auch über neue Mehrwert-Techniken und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Auch gerne über Uran und Plutonium-Gewinnung.
Über stuxnet wird sicherlich auf dem Correa einiges zu hören sein. Wir werden mal gucken, was da so an Vorträgen kommt. Wie gesagt, die Analysen laufen noch. Etliches davon ist momentan noch so ein bisschen unscharf und unklar. Zumal es auch so viele verschiedene Varianten gibt. Ansonsten der Flatter-Button auf der Homepage ist immer noch da. Wir sind für reichliche Benutzung dankbar. Dann können wir uns noch ein bisschen mehr Equipment-Upgrades leisten, obwohl dieser Fortschritt hier gerade doch schon sehr beachtlich ist.
Das Aufnahmegerät kränkelt ja gerade noch ein bisschen, aber...
Ja genau, das wäre so das nächste, was wir dann mal ersetzen wollen. Also wenn ihr uns noch bessere Technik gönnen wollt, dann drückt doch mal auf den Flatter-Button. Ansonsten, ja man kann auch für die älteren Sendungen flattern, falls ihr die noch nicht gehört habt. Die sind auch nicht so schlecht, wenn sie auch teilweise etwas akustischer anders sind als diese hier. Ansonsten wünschen wir euch noch viel Spaß und bis zum nächsten Mal.